[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver pour suivre l'événement phare
de la semaine au sénat les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
nous sommes ensemble tout l'après-midi
pour vous faire vivre ce temps fort de
l'actualité au parlement avec nos
journalistes nous sommes avec marie
pierre bourgeois qui se trouvent dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
alors marc hecker quel est le menu de
ces questions les sénateurs attendent de
pied ferme le gouvernement avec un
objectif savoir ce qui s'est réellement
passé lundi soir place de la république
lors de l'évacuation d'un camp de
migrants
effectivement il ya plusieurs questions
là dessus à tout à l'heure marie pier
alexandre poussard salle des conférences
pour toutes les réactions de les
sénateurs et des ministres à qui
allez-vous tendre votre micro alexandre
un bonjour tam et bien je serai d'abord
avec le sénateur socialiste sébastien
pla pour évoquer la réouverture des
commerces non essentiels à partir de
samedi
et puis j'interrogerai le président de
la commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat christian cambon pour parler du
conflit entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
et de la reconnaissance de la république
du haut karabagh qui est souhaité par
les sénateurs à tout à l'heure alexandre
également avec nous les streamer
politique jean mas siégeant qui va
commenter sur la plateforme twitch la
séance des questions d'actualité tout
cet après midi avec les internautes en
héritage on attend tous les questions
des sénateurs et des sénatrices
notamment suite à l'allocution
d'emmanuel macro hier ils doivent être
contents les sénateurs et sénatrices à
passer annonces de voitures des
commerces
on verra ça tout à leur écoute on va
également voir ça dans un instant sur ce
plateau
en attendant dans une demi-heure notre
face à face avec le sénateur l'est
républicain marc philippe daubresse et
le socialiste rachid t'es mal on va
revenir sur la polémique qui se poursuit
après que l'assemblée a adopté la loi
sur la sécurité globale et l'article 24
cet article qui interdit la diffusion
d'image de forces de l'ordre avec des
intentions malveillantes
est il utile peut-il porter atteinte à
la liberté d'informer faut-il le
réécrire on en parle à 14h30
[Musique]
mais d'abord on va revenir sur
l'allégement du confinement après
l'allocution et hier du président de la
république emmanuel macron at il tenu sa
promesse d'apporter cohérence clarté à
la stratégie du gouvernement on va en
parler avec l'a4 invité sylvie
vermeillet bonjour bonjour vous êtes à
sénatrice us et du jura et vous êtes co
rapporteur de la commission denquête
qu'ovide également avec nous rené paul
savary
bonjour vous êtes dessinateur et l'air
de la marne et vice président de cette
même commission d' enquête et nous
sommes également en visio avec deux
invités qu'ovide oblige william dab
bonjour vous êtes médecin vous êtes
professeur émérite de santé publique
ancien directeur de la direction
générale de la santé et enfin avec nous
le politologue bruno cautrès bonjour
vous êtes chercheur cnrs au cevipof et
professeur à sciences po on va décrypter
ensemble et bien toutes les annonces
d'hier du président de la république et
notamment celles qui concernent plus
particulièrement le parlement mais
d'abord comment les sénateurs ont ils
accueilli ces annonces marion delpech
c'est nous avons réussi à ralentir la
circulation du virus
nous ne devons pas perdre de vue nos
autres préoccupations sanitaires des
placements autorisés réouverture des
commerces les sénateurs salut pour la
plupart les annonces d'allègement des
restrictions mais des incertitudes
demeurent pour le patron du groupe
socialiste a évoqué éventuellement des
contraintes pour forcer les personnes
atteintes du coc vide de se retrouver en
isolement total
pourquoi pas mais rien sur les
infrastructures rien sur le comment pour
y parvenir rien sur le respect des
libertés individuelles et collectives
donc là un doute
puis il ya un grand trou dans la
raquette un grand angle mort comme le
disait d'ailleurs jean castex et la
question des jeunes pour la sénatrice
les républicains christine lagarde
la majorité des mesures annoncées tombe
sous le sens mais certaines apparaissent
contradictoires
j'ai entendu parler de la reprise des
activités extrascolaires de plein air
j'entends voilà là il ya quand même un
côté un peu absurdistan qui perdure
puisque ces enfants notamment quand on
pense aux plus petits les maternelles et
les primaires sont à l'école tous les
jours
d'autres mesures qui paraissent un peu
aussi absurde c'est la limitation à 30
personnes dans les lieux de culte
donc finalement on fait juste couvrir
avant on pouvait aller assister à des
obsèques désormais on pourra aller
pratiquer mes 35 30 personnes ça veut
dire ça ne tient même pas compte de la
taille de ces édifices
le sénateur centriste vincent
capo-canellas ce s'est félicité des
mesures prises pour les entreprises mais
estime qu'il en faudra davantage pour
venir en aide à tous les précaires alors
évidemment motion de la commission des
finances je vous dirais que le quoi
qu'il en coûte commence à chiffrer
beaucoup mais je pense que c'est plutôt
un pas positif quand même qui nous est
proposé et cette intervention avait au
moins ce mérite là ouvrir quelques
perspectives essaye de compter des dates
régler des situations il en reste
beaucoup encore qu'il faudra traiter
demain matin le premier ministre devrait
détailler ces mesures lors d'une
conférence de presse voilà on va en
savoir encore un petit peu plus demain
matin mais hier emmanuel macron a donc
fixé un calendrier qu'on peut résumer en
trois dates 28 novembre c'est la
première phase avec notamment la
réouverture des petits commerces
mais nous sommes toujours confiné on a
toujours besoin d'attestation pour se
déplacer le 15 décembre si nous arrivons
à rester à un seul de 5000 contamination
par jour et bien ça sera bien le début
du déconfinement va pouvoir se déplacer
dans toute la france à l'exception du
ski a pu y aura un couvre-feu et puis la
dernière date c'est le 20 janvier avec
la fin des dernières restrictions les
restaurants qui pourrait rouvrir et les
lycées repasser en 100% présentiel
sylvie vermeillet on a donc des
perspectives est ce que pour vous c'est
satisfaisant
alors pour moi c'est une grande
respiration
j'avais posé la question gouvernement la
semaine dernière en souhaitant le
décalage du black friday la réouverture
des commerces
c'est quand même une grande partie dès
la réouverture absolue alors je suis
très heureuse de ces éléments conjoint
réouverture des commerces et décalage du
black friday
c'était quand même extrêmement important
maintenant effectivement il
beaucoup de choses à préciser et puis
malgré tout en tant que co rapporteur de
la commission denquête qu'ovide tous les
éléments qui concerne la réorganisation
de l'hôpital et du système de santé
moi je suis encore très en attente voilà
ici un spécialiste qui va nous donner
son verdict même jeu
je regrette le président de la
république a dit qu'on avait su
s'adapter qu'on avait su se réorganiser
se réorganiser non pas sur le système de
santé pas encore même question rené paul
savary qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
perspectives donc qui ont été hier et
bien dressée par le chef de l'état
écoutez voyez des mesures qui ont été
prises qu'on n'avait pas compris comme
fermer les petits commerces
on est tous contents qu'il soit ouvert
mais ce soir il kiffe j'te dis c'est pas
les fermer pour leur ouverture
oui tout à fait le la promenade au delà
d'un kilomètre on l'a tous disent ça
rime à rien qu il vaut mieux que les
gens soient dehors plutôt que d'être
enfermé dans un espace confiné un bon on
commence à avoir effectivement pris
conscience que le déconfinement
précédent avait été raté donc il faut
prendre un certain nombre de mesures
il n'empêche que derrière le couvre-feu
par exemple me paraît bonne initiative
mais faire en sorte que les restaurants
sont ouverts tout de suite alors que
l'on peut prendre des mesures
sanitaire qui permettent aux gens de se
retrouver comme ils le font en famille
on va autoriser les gens les 24 le 31 à
se retrouver en famille à manger à 5 6
10 et autour de la table et on peut pas
le faire au restaurant parce que c'est
ce qui nous autorise à prendre pour les
fêtes de fin d'année mais le problème au
restaurant c'est que finalement on n'est
pas du tout sûr de trouver quoi qu'il
arrive un protocole sanitaire réagi si
c'est là qu'il faut imposer si vous leur
donnez vous les responsabiliser ce que
je trouve toujours dommage dans ces
mesures c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez
une de prise en compte de la
responsabilité des gens ils sont
capables de comprendre ce qu'ils
comprennent pas c'est les mesures qui
sont pas cohérentes
ce n'était pas de bon sens les petits
commerces n'ont pas compris on peut
aller en grande surface peut pas aller
dans la petite chose qui va pas donc il
faut des mesures claires s'ils peuvent
se retrouver et manger à 5,6 autour de
la table chez eux et pas manger à 5 6
dans les mêmes conditions au restaurant
avec les mesures adoptées et c'est là
qu'on peut prendre des compensations
parce que ça limite les capacités il ya
des charges supplémentaires etc
mais il faut retrouver une vie avec le
virus 1 et c'est pour ça que j'aurais
fait des mesures plus contraignantes moi
par exemple en ce qui concerne la
vaccination mais moins contraignante ans
qu'ils sont comme auxerre ni seulement
bon sens de la compréhension je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit forcément au rendez
vous on va parler vaccination isolement
mais il d'abord votre regard bruno
cautrès on a aussi entendu le président
de la république qui a plutôt et bien
saluer l'effort des français hier au
début d'une allocution à ce que pour
vous il a réussi à apporter d'avantagé
bien de cohérence à tout cela puisque on
lui avait reproché un certain flou voire
on l'a entendu certaines mesures qui ont
été jugés par les français absurde
wheeler premier premier point de
méthodes quand on analyse ses discours
d' emmanuel macron il faut toujours
aussi attend de voir quelle est la
déclinaison très précise que le premier
ministre et les ministres concernés vont
donner
donc tant qu'on n'a pas encore ces
précisions en particulier savez d'être
souligné sur la question d'un éventuel
isolement contraignant des personnes qui
sont contaminées
ou le paramétrage exacte de la
réouverture des commerces avec la
fameuse jauge à 8 mètres carrés par par
client tout le temps qu'on a pas ça
c'est vrai que c'est un peu difficile de
savoir si le présent à un public a
pleinement répondu aux attentes de
précisions de la part des français et de
pressions de la part des milieux
professionnels mais si l'objectif d'hier
c'était d'essayer de mettre fin à ce
sentiment qui est dominant dans
l'opinion publique c'est à dire le
sentiment d'être littéralement perdu
d'être complètement paumé dans la
situation c'est-à-dire de calais un
certain nombre de repères et de balises
temporel le 28e rang 15 et 100 20
janvier de ce point de vue là c'est pas
trop mal on va dire de ce point de vue
là c'est pas trop mal même si
l'explication est un peu longue
même si cette explication et et quand
même par étapes progressives qu'on
aurait pu rendre encore peut-être encore
plus plus simple en visualisant les
choses peut-être davantage confinement
allégé couvre-feu et déconfinement 1 par
exemple s'est dit de manière indirecte
par le chef de l'état on aurait pu s'y
32 mais encore beaucoup plus clair mais
si l'objectif était de concerts balisage
pour l'opinion publique et essayer de
sortir un petit peu de ce sentiment
d'être totalement perdu c'est vrai que
ça va pas fait de mal ce qui a été dit
hier je ne suis pas sûr néanmoins que ça
règle le totalement ce sentiment dans
l'opinion publique d'une forme peu de
d'incohérences relative chaos dans l'est
dans les dents les mesures donc il
faudra voir les enquêtes d'opinion qui
vont être dans les jours qui va voir ses
enquêtes on va continuer aussi les
réactions celle des conférences on va
rejoindre alexandre pouces arcade avec
le sénateur socialiste de l'eau de
sébastien pla pour une réaction plus
particulière - bien sûr la réouverture
au des petits commerces
oui oui et surtout l'aspect économique
de ce confinement allégé sébastien pla
cette réouverture des commerces dès
samedi c'est un soulagement
oui c'est un soulagement nous
l'appelions de nos voeux pas trop grande
surprise parce que je crois que c'est
une décision qui pouvait ne pas ne pas
perdurer
je vois le président au public ne
pouvait pas tenir cette position là
quand l'on voit les
les problématiques que rencontrent ces
commerces de proximité on a pas d'étude
clair sur l'impact du coc vide
par exemple chez votre voisin de
coiffure ou chez un libraire par rapport
à une enseigne de grande distribution
donc c'est une décision quand même assez
incompréhensible pour le secteur du
commerce
et puis bon moi je me pose quand même la
question ne sera qui profite le crime
parce que ce genre de décision t'es
lourd de conséquences derrière on voit
les résultats d'ecs affable notamment
d'amazon vous rendez compte je lisais ce
matin d'un chiffre qui est édifiant
amazon a réalisé sur le 3ème trimestre
de cette année plus de 5 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires c'est
colossal 60 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices c'est à dire l'équivalent du
déficit français annuel donc c'est
énorme
aujourd'hui ça pose vraiment une grosse
question de la taxation de ces
structures là justement pour pouvoir
payer les politiques publiques dans les
pays où ils font des bénéfices
c'est d'ailleurs le sénat a voté une
taxe exceptionnelle sur les géants du
numérique alors les commerces vont quand
même de voir appliquer un protocole
sanitaire strict avec huit mètres carrés
d'écart entre les clients mais pour
certains commerces ça va être compliqué
notamment les savants coiffure ça va
être compliqué en fonction de la taille
des commerces et bon gta 4 mètres carrés
avant confinement 8 aujourd'hui ça
devient très compliqué pour les plus
petits cela dit les mesures de
sanitaires existait avant le confinement
je vous disais tout à l'heure je connais
pas pourquoi on les a fermés de manière
arbitraire alors que pour la plupart
fonctionnait très bien il y avait des
fonctionnements et sanitaires qui
permettait de garantir la sécurité des
clients est en tout cas du côté des
restaurateurs et ben là c'est plus
compliqué puisqu'il ne pourront pas
ouvrir avant janvier
ça va encore et bien salée leur addition
leur facture de cette crise écoutez
c'est catastrophique
je suis désolé on dirait dans toute
crise il faut il faut bien sacrifier des
pans de l'économie
il ya des martyrs moi j'appelle les
restaurateurs les martyrs de la
république aujourd'hui
depuis le début ce secteur là est
complètement sacrifiés de toute
politique de réouverture jeu quand on
voit que avant le continent vous aviez à
peu près la moitié des entreprises du
chr café hôtellerie restauration bars et
boîtes de nuit menacé de ne plus exister
dès l'année prochaine de faire défaut
aujourd'hui on vous annonce des mesures
vous allez me dire le président propose
la mesure des 20% qui est appelé aussi
des voeux des femmes consulaires des
différentes structures de l'hôtellerie
le problème c'est que le mal est fait
déjà cette mesure là nous aurions dû la
mettre en oeuvre bien avant aujourd'hui
bon nombre de ces commerces la fermeront
leurs rideaux mais derrière vous savez
qu'une semaine de confinement et de
fermeture de l'ensemble des chercheurs
en france correspond à un milliard
d'euros de pertes chiffre d'affaires et
c'est tout l'écosystème qui gravitent
autour des restaurants qui est impactée
c'est à dire à l'industrie
agroalimentaire levens la viande le
fromage légumes
donc c'est la casse est énorme sur ce
secteur là aujourd'hui on voit pas de
perspectives puisque nous lire et
ouverture aux alentours du 20 janvier à
condition à condition donc mettez vous à
la place d'un hôtelier d'un restaurateur
c'est intenable
merci beaucoup sébastien pla pour votre
réaction est 8ème du coup du positif
pour les commerces et de l'inquiétude
pour les restaurateurs
voilà pour cette voix qui porte sur le
secteur économique et si on reste sur la
question sanitaire william dab est ce
que pour vous c'est un calendrier qui
est suffisamment prudent qui a adapté
par rapport aux derniers résultats au
dernier chiffre qu'on a pu avoir
concernant et bien l'épidémie de l'aco
vidant oui je le pense
la première chose souligné je pense
c'est quand même la rapidité avec
laquelle la courbe épidémique c'est
l'inversé je vous avoue que j'en suis
moi même surpris
heureusement surpris
ça montre que l'application des mesures
de prévention a été bien mieux respectés
qu'au cours du premier confinement mais
ce que ça veut dire
le risque est ce que ça veut dire qu'on
avait un peu et d'écouté c'est très
difficile c'est très difficile vous
savez les modèles ne peuvent pas tout
dire les bonnes elles ont surestimé par
exemple le nombre de malades
hospitalisés en réanimation
c'est très difficile nous sommes sur un
virus qui nous réserve toujours beaucoup
de surprises
de très nombreux facteurs influencent la
courbe la courbe épidémique et moi ce
que là j'ai apprécié dans la position du
président c'est ce côté pragmatique et
le fait que l'on va coller à l'évolution
de la courbe épidémique avec des
échéances qui ont été clarifiées qui
permettent je crois à tous les acteurs
de de se préparer et également le fait
que nous avons tiré les leçons des
échecs précédents pas tellement l'échec
du déconfinement du mois de mai qui a
pas été si mal géré que ça au contraire
je pense mais de l'échec des mois d'août
et septembre
ou quand on a vu la courbe épidémique
redémarrer les mesures n'ont pas été
prises suffisamment tôt et de ce point
de vue là je pense que la situation est
maintenant plus favorable et que le
président à clarifier de nombreux points
qui concerne les tests qui concerne l'
isolement et qui concerne une chose
qu'il faut bien comprendre jean
j'entends les doutes et les critiques
des parlementaires
je les comprends je les entends il y à
une pièce du pujol qui manque depuis le
début c'est la faiblesse de notre
recherche des sources de contamination
et là j'ai entendu j'ai lu le directeur
général de la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie qui dans le journal
le monde a fait comprendre que oui
cette source de contamination allait
maintenant être systématiquement
recherchés et quand nous aurons cette
cartographie des contaminations
alors on verra s'il est pertinent de
laisser fermer les cafés les restaurants
les coiffeurs etc
tant que nous n'avons pas ça c'est les
décisions sont difficiles parce qu'elles
sont prises dans le brouillard à l'est
et un autre sujet important aussi pour
ne pas reproduire les mêmes erreurs qu
en août et en septembre est menacée la
question de l' isolement des personnes
positives à l'aco vidé pour prévoir un
dispositif emmanuel macron demande au
parlement de se saisir du sujet on
écoute le présent la république hier
je souhaite que le gouvernement et le
parlement prévoit les conditions pour
s'assurer de l'isolément des personnes
contaminées y compris de manière plus
contraignante
un vrai débat démocratique doit se tenir
mais si nous voulons éviter un
confinement
nous devons être plus contraignant à
l'égard de celles et ceux qui ont le
virus
ces personnes seront accompagnés sur le
plan matériel sanitaire psychologique
cette nouvelle stratégie associera outre
les services de l'état les mères et
leurs services comme les associations
concernées
rené paul savary est ce que vous êtes
vous personnellement favorable à des
mesures plus contraignantes pour pouvoir
forcer les malades à s'isoler par quoi
ça pourrait passer
non je suis pas favorable des mesures
plus contraignantes
parce que je pense qu'il faut
responsabiliser les gens et dès
l'instant où il est dit entre nous si
une personne est diagnostiquée positive
c'est qu'elle a fait un test déjà donc
elle s'est prise en main donc elle peut
comprendre qu'elle peut rester chez
elles serveuse d'isoler éventuellement
met en tout cas un local à disposition
mais qu'est ce que ça peut faire si elle
sort et qu'elle va faire sa promenade
pendant une heure avec un masque dehors
en quoi est elle dangereuse 1 alors que
celui qui ne sait pas testé lui va
pouvoir se balader en toute liberté donc
attention à ces mesures contraignant les
gens ne vont plus testé mais surtout je
voudrais vous dire que je je je réagis
par rapport aux propos que je viens
d'entendre et que je partage ce sont des
mesures prédictive
on sait que maintenant le le virus se
multiplient au niveau des intestins de
des analyses d'eau qui peuvent permettre
de détecter par anticipation le virus
on a des mesures prédictive à prendre
qui feront que on anticipera plutôt que
de prendre des mesure où on court
toujours après le virus et la contrainte
de l'isolément c'est une mesure où en
cours après le virus n'est pas une
mesure d'anticipation et c'est bien
regrettable
ce qui est important quand on y est
diagnostiqué de quelqu'un c'est bien
c'est de savoir qui va contaminer mais
d'où vient sa contamination
c'est ce qu'on ne fait pas alors que
c'est pas plus difficile on peut le
faire surtout avec les moyens
informatiques et avec les moyens mise en
en ordre pour justement recherché les
cas contacts alors sylvie vermeillet
pour l'instant le président de la
république
il a plutôt mis l'accent en tout cas et
bien sûr l'isolément des personnes qui
qui qui sont malades
est ce que c'est pour vous le sujet le
plus important aujourd'hui on entend
aussi aujourd'hui dire qu'il faut aussi
les mesures d'accompagnement il faut
aussi les aides
voilà si on est parent dans une famille
monoparentale enfin pour quelqu'un pour
vous aider à faire les courses
c'est énormément de contraintes quand
même de d'isoler une personne le sujet
c'est que on apprend et on est encore en
train d'apprendre de cette deuxième
vague on a appris de la première on
apprendre la deuxième on essaye à chaque
fois et c'est vrai qu'on est tributaire
de la recherche et de l'évolution de de
tous nos spécialistes de la santé qui
vont nous aider nous éclairer mais on
doit déjà se préoccuper d'éviter une
troisième vague et on se demande à quoi
on n'a encore pas fait face et ça
suppose une acceptation de la société à
une évolution permanente c'est ça qui
est difficile aujourd'hui c'est que à
chaque fois la vague est différente et à
chaque fois on me demande des évolutions
qui sont parfois difficilement sur nos
têtes religieusement quand même pose que
ce que je veux dire c'est que si il doit
y avoir un isolement s'il doit y avoir
des mesures j'espère bien qu'on va
s'appuyer plus fortement sur les mers ça
a été à mon avis ratés au niveau de la
première vague
j'espère qu'on prendra réellement la
tâche des mers et pas forcément de la rs
qui je regrette est toujours pas adapté
une gestion de crise il faut que la
grèce s'appuie sur les mers
pour ces situations d'isolement vérifier
si effectivement il ya des services à
disposition pour accompagner les gens
william dab est ce que l' isolement a
été pour vous l'un des points noirs de
la stratégie pour l'instant il ya cette
tribune dans le parisien appelant à une
meilleure politique d'isolement en quoi
ça consisterait pour voir écouter soyons
clairs du point de vue de
l'épidémiologie l'isolément des
personnes contagieuses et la cli de la
maîtrise du risque
y en a pas d'autre ça fait longtemps
comme c'est plus d'un siècle
c'est la base de la lutte contre les
épidémies l'isolément des personnes
contagieuses
donc c'est ça c'est ça la clé est-ce
qu'il faut recourir à des mesures
contraignantes ce que j'ai surtout
entendu du président c'est le mot
accompagnement moi je fais effectivement
confiance à la responsabilité des shows
mais il faut les mettre
il faut rendre ce confinement de sept
jours vivable faisable et ça ça demande
un accompagnement de terrain oui ce sont
les maires je pense qu'ils sont les
mieux placés pour l'organiser avec le
réseau associatif les centres communaux
d'action sociale
c'est là que l'effort doit porter je
suis méfiant vis-à-vis de l'obligation
pour la raison que le sénateur viens
viens de dire
et c'est par exemple une des grandes
leçons que l'on a tiré de la lutte
contre l'épidémie de sida
si on utilise des mesures de contrainte
les gens développeront et stratégies
pour se soustraire au reste et ça ce
serait la pire des choses parce que le
circulent eux de virus circulera de
façon cachée avant de recourir à des
mesures contraignantes que le parlement
débattre c'est une très bonne chose
mettons en place un accompagnement
efficace de ces gens au front gens des
lieux liberté
mon adapté quand ils ne peuvent pas être
confinée ce jeu c'est une question de
sept jours maintenant
et ceci doit être accompagnée il faut
parfois on est les enfants à l'école
il faut aller les chercher vous pouvoir
faire les courses faire les repas il
faudrait un accompagnement local au cas
par cas et si nous faisons l'épidémie
sera maîtrisée et bruno cautrès est
important que ça passe par la voie du
parlement par par les parlementaires par
les représentants du peuple pour prévoir
un isolement qui serait à la fois
acceptable respectant nos libertés avec
parce qu'il représente forcément et bien
une certaine contrainte pour les
français du pointu de la légitimité
démocratique d'une privation éventuelle
de liberté c'est fondamental évidemment
en revanche que je voudrais souligner c
qui serait hautement souhaitable que le
parlement lorsqu'il va débattre de tout
ceci
effectivement tir de sacrés leçons de ce
qui s'est passé depuis le début du
confinement depuis le début de
l'épidémie où nous avons vu à plusieurs
reprises des décisions prises au niveau
central être absolument dans
l'incapacité d'avoir des traductions
empirique concrètes et ce que je redoute
beaucoup c'est l'écart entre de grands
principes et des réalités totalement
défaillante lorsque vous parlez aux gens
à gauche et à droite de leur expérience
vous rencontrerez des gens qui vont vous
expliquer qui s'est passé des fois
plusieurs semaines entre le moment où
ils ont été diagnostiqués positifs que
vident et où ils ont reçu un courrier de
l'assurance maladie leur disant de se
protéger plusieurs semaines après le
résultat du test il y à des défaillances
empirique concrètes absolument majeur et
ne faudrait pas qu'on retourne vers un
nouveau une boucle qui se re de grands
principe est alors des réalité empirique
concrètes véritablement concrètes
défaillante
si nous allons vers ça il faut vraiment
que le parlement débattre des moyens des
responsabilités de qui fait quoi qui est
qu'elle est l'accompagnement pas
seulement des citoyens mais qu'elle est
l'accompagnement de ceux qui sont
chargés de la mise en oeuvre
comment est-ce qu'on peut détecter les
défaillances les délais donc voilà de
quoi il faut parler de manière précise
pour ne pas revivre à nouveau une grande
déception nationale des défaillances à
ne pas reproduire alors qu'on commence à
voir la lumière au bout du tunnel qui on
commence à voir de bonnes nouvelles
concernant les vaccins et que notre pays
doit se préparer concrètement à une
véritable campagne de vaccination pour
françois baroin le maire ait l'air de
trois présidents de l'association des
maires de france il faut justement est
bien à nouveau sur ce sujet associés
très étroitement les élus locaux les
maires écoutez le l'état et n'est pas en
situation aujourd'hui sur la base de ces
locaux et autres de mener une campagne
de vaccination sur les communes mais ça
faut être très conscient de ça je parle
pas de regard sur le fond le choix du
vaccin appartiendra à l'état je ne parle
pas je ne porte pas un regard sur la
décision de la communication autour de
la campagne de vaccination
quel public à quel rythme selon quelle
méthode ce n'est pas notre affaire
en revanche je dis que pour y parvenir
et pour le faire accepter son les maires
ce rendez vous là ce sera un échec comme
celui de la première partie du
confinement concernant la logistique sur
les masques et comme celui sur la
première partie du déconfinement sur les
tests eh oui rené paul savary vous êtes
d'accord avec françois barois il faut
mieux associer les élus locaux sinon on
peut reproduire les fiascos les
difficultés qu'on a eues avec les
masques les tests sur les vaccins bien
sûr bien sûr il faut une vraie stratégie
une déclinaison locale c'est curieux un
moment où on prenait des mesures
nationales à prendre les attentions faux
territorialisée puisque l'épidémie n est
pas tout à fait au même niveau
moi dans mon appartement je peux vous
dire qu'elle a été touchée parce qu il n
a pas la preuve
la deuxième elle et elle et elle est
réglée et si on veut que ça se réalise
bien faut accompagner les gens au plus
près de chez eux en conséquence ce sont
les maires et les médecins généralistes
qui sont en première ligne et de façon
tout à fait logique compréhensible ils
connaissent la population ils
connaissent les patients c'est eux qui
deux seront qui seront convaincants pour
que les gens se vaccine parce que
derrière faut véritablement avoir son
son pouvoir de de convaincre les gens
parce qu'on connaît les difficultés la
réticence de nos concitoyens vis-à-vis
de la vaccination donc très important
william dab vous êtes d'accord c'est ça
qu'il faut il faut à la fois les élus
locaux et pire n'est pas le savary
disait aussi et bien faire confiance aux
médecins généralistes pour instaurer
cette confiance avec les français
un pays où on sait bien il ya une grande
défiance en quasiment la moitié des
français sont aujourd'hui méfiant oui je
pense qu'il faut relativiser relativiser
ce chiffre il ya beaucoup de choses
comme sait pas encore sur le vaccin
d'abord ils n'ont pas encore
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
donc attendons ça va arriver en décembre
est attendu à partir de ce moment là que
la moitié des gens sourds sont
attentistes vis-à-vis du vaccin n'est
pas une preuve de résistance
c'est une preuve de prudence
deuxièmement je suis d'accord avec ce
qui vient d'être dit les maires vont
avoir un rôle à jouer les médecins c'est
fondamental il n'y aura pas de
vaccination réussi dans le pays sans que
les médecins soient associés ce qui pose
des problèmes compliqués parce qu'en
dotant d'un vaccin qui doit être gardée
à moins 70 degrés il n'y a pas de
congélateur de ce type là chez les
médecins
ça va poser des problèmes on peut les
résoudre mais il ya quand même une
difficulté
enfin il faut penser au département
aussi tout indique que les personnes
hébergées dans les ehpad se feront
partie des publics prioritaires de
nombreux ehpad dépendent de département
donc l'association des élus locaux mais
et conseillers départementaux et prêt
est très important il va falloir une
mobilisation générale pour réussir ses
campagnes de de vaccination région le
redis l'association des médecins va être
un facteur clé pour le succès il nous
reste juste quelques minutes ce bruno
cautrès très rapidement vous êtes
d'accord
la confiance elle va aussi et bien
monter à mesure que tout cela va être
plus opérationnel et qu'on va pouvoir
avoir un vaccin en qui tout le monde a
confiance et on sait comment pour
l'instant on n'est pas on n'est pas
encore prêt et c'est bien normal mais il
sait fondamentale tout ce qui vient
d'être dit est absolument capital la
confiance c'est à la fois la proximité
mais aussi la réciprocité j'ai confiance
si je vois que ma confiance est de
retour et donc ça c'est absolument
fondamental que le principe de proximité
et de proximité pour l'efficacité soit
l'alpha et l'oméga de cette politique me
semble absolument capital c'est aussi
une leçon que l'exécutif peut
communiquer en disant qu'il a fait son
retour d'expérience et qu'il est capable
le pouvoir exécutif de nous dire ce qui
n'a pas fonctionné et quelles sont les
leçons qu'il en tire et je crois que là
on tient quelque chose d'extrêmement
important parce qu'effectivement il n'y
aura pas de succès de de long terme et
si on veut que cette épidémie nous aide
aussi à faire des progrès collectifs sur
tout un tas d'autres sujets et bien il y
aura pas ce progrès collectif s'il n'ya
pas effectivement une forte une forte
dose de confiance des citoyens allez le
mot de la fin sylvie vermeillet tu sûr
sur ce sujet sur les vaccins
heureusement que le président de la
république a exprimé clairement sa
volonté de ne pas le rendre obligatoire
sinon c'était une des filles enlevées
assuré il a besoin de l'adhésion des
français qui sont aujourd'hui
relativement perdu donc ne pas rendre ce
vaccin obligatoire c'était vraiment
élémentaire et j'ai pause je pense que
c'est le premier pas vers une adhésion
qui serait nécessaire eh bien merci
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat nous sommes
maintenant à moins d'une demi-heure du
début des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
nous sommes toujours avec alexandre
poussard salle des conférences il va
avoir de nombreux invités à son micro
également jean macé est en train de
discuter d'interroger sa communauté sur
la plateforme twitch il va nous dire
aujourd'hui bien ce qui préoccupe les
internautes et puis marie pierre
bourgeois se trouve dans l'hémicycle du
sénat et marie-pierre vous allez pouvoir
nous détailler un petit peu plus le
programme des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
oui beaucoup dans toute chose au money
aujourd'hui femmes vous le savez un
c'est la journée internationale de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
des agressions malheureusement aggravée
par la crise le groupe communiste et le
groupe socialiste vont interpeller
d'abriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement sur le sujet notamment sur
la question des moyens qui font
cruellement défaut
j'ai les associations les sénateurs 1
vont revenir également sur les annonces
des manuels macron hier autour du
déconfinement ya une vraie inquiétude
aujourd'hui sur le banc des socialistes
des centristes et des républicains celle
que le gouvernement passe à côté de la
précarité et la souffrance psychologique
enfin les sénateurs des sénateurs pardon
attendaient de pied ferme
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est finalement marlène
schiappa sa ministre délégué qui sera
présente
cet après midi elle va devoir répondre
dans l'hémicycle à deux sujets d'abord
le projet de loi sécurité globale qui va
pénaliser la diffusion jugées
malveillantes d'image de policier c'est
une mesure que beaucoup de gens qui est
un peu la liberté de la presse
elle va devoir aussi s'expliquer sur
l'évacuation musclée d'un camp de
migrants place de la république
lundi soir le patron du groupe
écologiste guillaume gontard d'ailleurs
l'interpellé un là dessus et puis enfin
le groupe
lr interrogera le gouvernement sur la
politique migratoire de la france
merci merci beaucoup marie pia on
retrouve dans 30 minutes à peu près on
va d'ailleurs revenir et bien dans cette
deuxième partie 2
l'émission serait bien cette polémique
qui se poursuit après que l'assemblée a
adopté la loi sur la sécurité globale et
notamment cet article 24 articles qui
interdit la diffusion d'image de forces
de l'ordre avec des intentions
malveillantes parce que c'est utile pour
protéger les policiers peut-il porter
atteinte à la liberté d'informer faut-il
leur écran va se poser toutes ces
questions mais d'abord le point sur ce
texte et le contexte avec baptiste
lépinay hier les députés ont adopté la
loi sur la sécurité globale
le texte et son article 24 prévoit
notamment de pénaliser la diffusion
malveillante de l'image des policiers en
réponse aux critiques jugeant cette loi
liberticide
le premier ministre a annoncé qu'il
saisirait lui même le conseil
constitutionnel pour que ne subsiste
aucun doute sur notre ferme intention
d'assurer l'indispensable protection de
nos forces de sécurité dans lanthier
respect de nos libertés démocratiques et
de l'état de droit
je vous annonce que je saisirai moi même
le conseil constitutionnel
ce vote intervient à la suite des images
d'évacuations violente d'un camp
éphémère de migrants place de la
république
guillaume gontard président du groupe
écologiste sénat va interpeller
aujourd'hui le gouvernement sur la
nécessité d images moi je je je
quand je repense à tous à ces images je
suis totalement totalement révolter et
je pense ne pas être le seul j'irais
hélas ça a permis de mettre en lumière
justement ce qu'on disait que cette
liberté de la presse que le rôle des
images avait son importance et que pour
le coup gérald et marc darman sont nés
sont aperçus pour la majorité
sénatoriale
il faut surtout trouver le curseur entre
protection des policiers et libertés moi
je soutiens les chances de l'ordre je
regrette les bavures et
et les excès mais il faut voir le
contexte global dans lequel ce type
d'incident arrive on va voir si ces
déséquilibres sont respectés vous savez
que c'est nike très attentif au respect
des équilibres dans les textes dits
sécuritaire et que donc on ne manquera
pas évidemment de veiller à la place du
curseur
prochaine étape le passage de la loi au
sénat prévu au mois de janvier
et justement sur ce plateau on va
pouvoir débattre de tout cela avec marc
philippe daubresse bon jour en jour vous
êtes un sénateur les républicains du
nord et vous allez être le co rapporteur
de cette proposition de loi sur la
sécurité globale au sénat également avec
nous rachid tu es mal bonjour sénateur
socialiste du val d'oise on va parler du
texte mais on va d'abord dire un mot du
contexte le contexte bien sûr et bien
c'est cette interpellation plus que
musclée avec des images de violence
lundi soir place de la république lors
du démantèlement d'un camp de migrants
marc philippe daubresse est ce que ces
images pour vous eh bien elles sont
choquantes elles sont inacceptables
notamment aussi ce qu'a dit gérald
darmanin
oui elles sont choquantes bien sûr moi
j'étais ministre du logement vous savez
donc j'ai eu en charge ses problèmes y
compris la lutte contre la pauvreté il
ya quinze ans maintenant je pense pas
qu'on avait fait des évacuations si
musclée je pense pour autant qu'il faut
pas jeter l'opprobre sur l'ensemble des
policiers les policiers exécute un art
qui est de dire il ya des personnes sans
papiers
quelque part on les évacue de la place
de la république
par contre la manière dont sa manière
d'ici ont évacué et est très grave et là
dessus je suis d'accord avec votre
commentaire
heureusement que des images pour montrer
tout ça et pour attester que ces percées
policiers qui ont employé des méthodes
choquantes doivent être sanctionnés pour
autant il faut pas jeter l'opprobre sur
tous les policiers qui ont un métier
extrêmement difficile en ce moment et
qui pour la plupart font bien leur
métier alors insisté mme alain marc
daubresse le dit cela montre
l'importance d'avoir des images de ce
type d'événement vous vous avez
d'ailleurs écrit une lettre à gérald
darmanin
naître solennelle qu'est ce que vous lui
demandez à l'intérieur concernant ces
événements d'un mot d'abord sur ce qui
est choquant ce qu'on avait là public ce
qui est choquant c'est des gens qui sont
là nuit d'orge qu'il faut jamais
l'oublier parce que attention à ne pas
c'est parce que dit mon collègue mais ne
pas nous habituer à cela ça c'est
choquant et après c'est vrai que encore
une fois il y à des actes de certains
policiers c'est effectivement sur ces
policiers là qui agissent en dehors à
toute déontologie de tout respect des
lois qu'il faut sévir et donc
effectivement donc pourquoi j'ai écrit à
monsieur darmanin c'est que on voit bien
à cette occasion deux choses d'une part
que la question de pouvoir filmer deux
cas d'avoir une presse libre la liberté
d'expression je rappelle c'est ce que
nous disons nous en france de par le
monde sur la liberté d'expression la
liberté la presse dont il faut pas
l'entraver par l'article 24 et je jouais
de la demande c'est aussi dire comme
vous avez demandé des rapports d'une
part au préfet de police de paris et
d'autres pas à l'igpn
je demande à ce que ces rapports la soie
aussi donné aux parlementaires parce que
je crois que dans le travail des
parlementaires et dans le contrôle du
pouvoir c'est un élément important
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur qui était ce matin l'invité
de nos confrères de france 2 il sait lui
là encore exprimé autour des violences
place de la république
en l'écoutant cette évacuation était
totalement légitime il ya eu ensuite de
la part de quelques policiers des gestes
inacceptables
donc moi je devrai d'abord pensé qu' il
faut que la justice se saisisse le
procureur la réplique l'a fait pour un
geste que vous avez vu l'igpn c'est à
l'inspection de la piste fait pour
d'autres gestes je rendrai public ces
rapports et si jamais tout cela
effectivement est vérifiée je prendrai
des sanctions mais je vais pas condamner
ni l'intégralité des policiers des
gendarmes qui sont intervenus sur cette
place ni le préfet de police pour les
faits de quelques-uns
ces quelques uns doivent être
sanctionnés et je veux redire que les
forces de l'ordre dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles son travail ils
ont beau sociale voilà les rapports
seront donc rendue publique et les
parlementaires pourront y avoir accès
marc philippe daubresse est ce que vous
jugez que ces actes de violence de la
part de ces policiers ont pu être
favorisée par ce contexte autour de
cette proposition de loi sécurité
globale est ce qu'il ya eu des poly'sons
pas le
un bon il se trouve qu'il ya coïncidence
entre cet article 2 le projet de loi de
cette proposition de loi dont on va
parler et puis ce qui s'est passé mais
vous savez moi j'ai traversé des moments
aussi difficiles dans la charge du
logement
je pense d'ailleurs que temps que
j'étais en charge avec mon ami jean
louis borloo
on a eu aucune bavure on a même fait des
moratoires vis-à-vis de population très
socialement des femmes défavorisées mais
quelque part c'est c'est l'ensemble de
la chaîne du logement qui est montré du
doigt parce que quelque part quand vous
avez des personnes qui sont à la rue et
que derrière vous avez des personnes qui
devraient être dans des logements
sociaux mais qu'on met dans des centres
d'hébergement où on pourra accueillir
provisoirement des personnes qui sont à
la rue c'est bien toute la chaîne qui
est en piste et et ça veut dire que
depuis mad mais malheureusement
plusieurs années il ya une chaîne du
logement qui ne fonctionnent plus et il
ya des défaillances sur la politique
globale du logement en france et donc on
peut être dans l'émotion et dans
l'événementiel mais il faut quand même
se dire que sur le fond il ya des
problèmes qui sont aujourd'hui pas bien
traité par le gouvernement actuel
on ne parle de l'article 24 est-ce que
cet article 24 tel qu'il a été adopté
par l'assemblée il aurait empêché de
filmer ses actes non noté que 24 permet
permet non mais cela n'empêche la
diffusion malveillants oui mais il ya
deux choses distinctes si vous voulez
mon collègue s'exprimant mais je veux
dire il ya la liberté de la presse qui
doit être sanctuarisée il faut
absolument pas touché il faut pas ne
serait-ce que trop gras vecteur en
tremblant à cette liberté de la presse
c'est une valeur des droits de l'homme
et de la république française donc on ne
voudra pas y toucher
il va falloir réécrire l'article
l'article i touch l'article les touches
oui bien m en 10 ans et quelque part cet
article n'aurait pas empêché que l'on
filmé que l'on diffuse des images pour
autant tel qu'il est écrit il est
juridiquement à certains et les
politiquement désastreux on va continuer
à parler de la rédaction de cet article
mais on entend aussi la crainte de la
part des journalistes mais papa que
celle des des citoyens sur cet article
24 c'est aussi qu' on puisse arriver à
une forme d'autocensure de la part des
journalistes cite aussi que les
policiers bien ils empêchent de filmer
parce qu'il va avoir une interprétation
très restrictive de la loi on entend des
policiers qui disent
mais vous n'avez plus le droit de filmer
aujourd'hui alors même que ce texte
n'est même pas encore adopté d'un mot
d'abord sur le logement parce que c'est
important ce que dit mon collègue il a
raison je rappelle que sous ce
gouvernement il ya une loi qui a été
votée sur le logement et on disait tous
à l'époque dans l'hémicycle que ça
allait casser la dynamique de
construction c'est le cas et en ile de
france je rappelle des airs en ile de
france je rappelle que valérie pécresse
n'êtes plus les communes qui ont déjà
plus de 30 % de logements sociaux alors
ça peut être une bonne idée comme cela
mais comme notre côté y'a pas de
contraintes ailleurs pour construire on
a bien là aussi pu assez de stock et
donc plus de possibilités de faire
entrer les gens sur la question vous
évoquez la moire encore une fois il ya
deux règles à la fois la protection
légitime et naturelle des policiers des
forces de police dans le cas de la
fonction de l'heure qui a pas de
dérapage ou de bavures l'autre côté la
liberté de la presse effectivement les
deux on doit on doit les sanctuariser ce
texte là je crois que c'est un texte
d'opportunités du preuve du ministre de
l'intérieur qu'ils aillent deux
syndicats qui se termine quand même dans
une histoire invraisemblable vous est le
premier objet d'appeler à lui-même aux
conséquences ionel tout ça démontre
qu'il ya un peu quand même de pas très
sérieux en tout cas et après sur le
principe oui nous concerne nous que la
liberté de la presse doit être
sanctuarisée il est hors de question et
le groupe socialiste
si le texte devait être en l'état mais
il y aura un travail au sénat on est
opposé il y aura tout à l'heure une
question d'heures qui sera posée par
jérôme durain pour notre groupe et donc
nous considérons qu'il faut
effectivement faire attention parce
qu'il ya un risque aussi de
d'autocensure est en tout cas de créer
un climat où la presse se sentiraient
j'ai un très honnêtement et j'en dirais
injuste d'un mot il ya quelques semaines
ont manifesté en manifestent tous
notamment je pense à charlie hebdo et
autres et je veux pas de comparaison
malveillants que les choses soient bien
claires on dit une des marques de la
france une des grandes heures de la
france c'est la liberté de la presse
ben je crois qu on doit chaque jour la
renforcer et veillez à ce qu'elle soit
une réalité dans notre pays
alors ce qu'il va falloir entièrement
réécrire le texte marqué nous sauver
nous sommes au sénat d'accord vous savez
moi j'ai fait pas mal de choses sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme et j'ai
toujours essayé de garder cet équilibre
qui est la marque de cette maison
d'abord décrire les choses juridiquement
très clairement et ensuite de faire la
part des choses entre le respect a dit
pas indispensable de certaines libertés
dont la liberté de la presse et la
liberté d'expression et d'autre part
pouvoir garantir qu'on protège les
policiers oui mais pas seulement les
gendarmes les surveillants
pénitentiaires les agents dans les
municipalités qui peuvent déceler et
donc voilà la règle est donc bah je vais
vous dire on va travailler moi je vais
auditionné bien sûr et je vais écouter
mes collègues et et richard que mal le
le sait à la commission des lois il ya
une grande écoute entre tout le monde
donc mais je pense qu'il faut sortir de
ce 2 de ceux de cet article tout ce qui
touche à la loi de 1881 sur la presse
parce qu'autrement vous aurez toujours
les risques de procès d'intention ou
deux on fait pas parce qu'on a peur que
et c'est donc faux de sortir de là par
contre que ssq audible président larcher
du sénat que l'on puisse renforcer les
dispositifs pour protéger des personnes
dans la diffusion sur internet de d'un
certain nombre de choses notamment dans
les réseaux sociaux là on peut le faire
avec un dispositif pénal et non pas un
dispositif qui touche à cette loi de
liberté de la presse donc je vous dis
davance je vais m'orienter vers une
règle et sûrs complète dans laquelle on
sortira le tout ce qui touche à la
liberté de la presse et en garantira on
sanctuary 'sera si vous préférez cette
liberté de la presse
très rapidement ça roule ça rouvre le
débat sur les tous qui propose notamment
sur sur les réseaux sociaux
je rappelle qu'il y avait un débat au
dessus on nous avait un peu cadenassé
punchy pas le sénat mais le gouvernement
comme quoi c'était pas aigles à l'époque
et attention à ne jamais mettre dans le
même débat la question les questions de
sécurité et la liberté de la presse
c'est aussi je crois quelque chose qu'il
faut avoir en tête parce que c'est aussi
pour cela que nous sommes nous une
grande nation
allez on parle internet on parle réseaux
sociaux on va rejoindre maintenant j'en
massiet qui justement interroge sa
communauté sur la plateforme twitch
depuis maintenant 45 minutes
jean tu vas suivre aussi avec le bas
tout à l'heure toutes les questions
d'actu qu'est ce qui fait réagir les
internautes
est ce que c'est ce dont on parle
maintenant écoute ta me oui évidemment
ce qui fait réagir les internautes le
plus en ce moment c'est toutes les
questions les clarifications attendues
de la part du gouvernement sur ce qu'a
annoncé emmanuel macron hier alors
évidemment il ya une grande glissade
après à la prévert tous les internautes
veulent savoir est-ce qu'on va avoir des
nouvelles attestations qui vont pouvoir
nous permettre de faire des achats non
essentiels les courses de noël par
exemple
des questions aussi sur les contrôles
renforcés des cas contact emmanuel
macron à parler de l' isolement des
personnes malades
ça va prendre quelle forme à quoi ça va
ressembler la question la politique
vaccinale aussi est abordé beaucoup
d'internautes qui voudraient savoir
comment ça va se passer qu'elles vont
être les publics prioritaires
à partir de quelle date on va pouvoir se
faire vacciner on sait que la
vaccination ne sera pas obligatoire
c'est ce qu'a voulu dire le président de
la république hier soir mais est-ce
qu'elle va être fortement conseillé
comment ça va s'organiser tout ça en
fait ya des vraies questions sur le mois
de janvier puis par ailleurs des
questions aussi plus spécifique de la
part des internautes sur la vie
étudiante des idées des internautes qui
aimerait bien en savoir un petit peu
plus de la part par exemple de faire des
vidals la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur
la réouverture des facs et pourquoi en
les stages du deuxième semestre qui
commence à se préparer
beaucoup d'étudiants sont en train de
chercher leur stage est ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire des stages comment ça va
se passer il ya vraiment une vraie
inquiétude de la part des étudiants
et puis par ailleurs les autres sujets
dans l'actualité sont aussi très attendu
on attend de la part des sénateurs
qu'ils posent des questions au
gouvernement sur le maintien de l'ordre
place de la république gérald darmanin
le ministre l'intérieur est très
attendue sur ce qu'il s'est passé place
de la république
avant-hier et jean michel blanquer le
ministre l'éducation nationale sur la
fère à venir lycéens ce syndicat lycéen
dont il aurait parait pas participé à la
création
là aussi on attend des explications de
la part du ministre de l'éducation
nationale
voici à peu près les grands sujets qu'on
attend merci merci beaucoup aux gens
c'est très complet et on va tout de
suite aller salle des conférences pour
une réaction celle de xavier iacovelli
bien pour rester sur cette thématique
qu'on est en train d'évoquer en plateau
et notamment et bien l'évacuation de la
place de la république lundi soir c'est
avoue alexandre et oui et xavier
iacovelli qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
de ces images de cette évacuation
musclée de migrants place de la
république à paris
écoutez moi j'ai été profondément choqué
par par la gestion par les méthodes
aujourd'hui qui on est et qui ont été
employés par certains
membre des forces de l'ordre je ne dis
pas je ne fais pas une généralité mais
c'est vrai que les images étaient assez
choquant j'ai pu m'exprimer
hier sur d'autres plateaux télé sur le
sujet je pense que
il était nécessaire que le ministre
demande une enquête une enquête d'abord
un rapport au préfet de police et puis
une enquête de l'igpn
nous ça nous a poussés aussi la
territoire de progrès par
l'intermédiaire de de la voix de notre
délégué général gilles savary devoir de
progresser la gauche de la république en
marche non c'est pas la gauche de la
république en marche c'est un parti
social démocrate dans la majorité
présidentielle d'accord et donc on a
fait une proposition de la création
d'une autorité indépendante de contrôle
qui remplacerait l'igpn aussi pour avoir
plus de transparence peut-être sur sur
ses modes de contrôle et puis pour
retrouver cette confiance entre les
citoyens et nos institutions je pense
que c'est indispensable en ce moment
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un vrai
problème avec toutes ces enquête de
l'igpn notamment sur les violences de
certains policiers des enquêtes qui ne
sont pas indépendantes
je ne sais pas s'il ya des problèmes
mais je pense qu'il est important de
recréer cette confiance et on crée la
confiance par de la transparence et donc
une autorité indépendante permet
justement de lever toutes les ambiguïtés
qui qui pourrait être soulevée par nos
concitoyens alors autre sujet qui
concerne les forces de l'ordre la
proposition de loi sécurité globale et
notamment l'article 24 sur la diffusion
malveillantes d'image des policiers en
intervention
ce texte il a été adopté à l'assemblée
nationale il va donc arriver au sénat et
xavier iacovelli est ce que vous le
vôtre et et notamment l'article 24 alors
que témoin il ya effectivement l'article
24 il ya la proposition de loi dans son
ensemble et jamais je voudrais saluer le
travail parlementaire et législatif de
mes deux collègues à l'assemblée
nationale qui ont fait 2 ans d'auditions
deux ans de travail pour aboutir à cette
proposition de loi
cette proposition de la scène n'est pas
limité à l'article 24 c'est aussi la
création de la police municipale à paris
c'est aussi la montée en compétences et
en formation de nos policiers municipaux
sur l'ensemble du territoire ces dix
mille agents supplémentaires c'est aussi
des avancées fortes pour pour la
sécurité après sur la question de
l'article 24 mois à titre personnel je
les dis je pense qu'il faut aussi sortir
des ambiguïtés à la fois il faut
protéger nos forces de l'ordre protéger
de tout ce qui pourrait nuire à
l'intégrité physique ou psychique de de
nos forces de l'ordre mais d'ailleurs
moi j'étais de ceux qui proposaient de
l'élargir à l'ensemble des agents
publics
territoriaux nationaux mais aussi aux
forces de secours les pompiers par
exemple qui subissent également des
attaques
donc moi je pense qu'il faut quelque
chose de plus large et je pense que pour
sortir de cette ambiguïté on a besoin de
réécrire cet article 24
je pense qu'il faut le déconnecter aussi
de de la question de la liberté de la
presse puisque ce n'est ça ne doit pas
être lié et il faut préserver cette
liberté de la presse je crois que le
premier ministre l'a dit l'a affirmé
dans l'hémicycle mais c'est je pense pas
encore assez affirmée et je pense que
l'article 25 de la loi sur les
séparatismes qui va arriver au parlement
à partir du mois de décembre ou janvier
je crois l'assemblée nationale va nous
permettre aussi d'avoir une plus on va
dire des dépositions beaucoup plus large
sur la question de la sécurité d'accor
donc une réécriture profonde au sénat de
cet article de 24 mois je le swing
effectivement d'accord et on est dans ce
cas là vous le vôtre et je verrai
comment y sera réécrit ok très bien
merci beaucoup avait accueilli pour
votre réaction
à quelques minutes avant cette séance de
questions d'actualité voilà donc ça
montre que tout le monde est d'accord
pour réécrire complètement l'article 24
au sénat y compris les sénateurs qui
appartiennent à la majorité
présidentielle
vous comptez sur moi pour le faire
l'année mais ce sera fait excusez moi de
le dire à la méthode sénatoriales j'ai
été député 25 ans ont réagi beaucoup à
l'assemblée sur l'instant et dans
l'événement nous ici on réagit en
fonction du droit avec déséquilibrée des
valeurs con con qu'on veut respecter
c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous donne comme
feuille de route le président larcher et
donc je pense qu'on va arriver à une
rédaction qui satisfera peut-être pas
tout le monde mais qui sera
juridiquement correct et qui protégera
les principes fondamentaux ce qui est
assez dommage c'est quand même que la
clique en marche et leurs députés de les
voter hier à dire c'est un peu ça qui
est dramatique série vote et puis
maintenant disons des prêts à bouger bas
il fallait pas voter une proposition une
proposition de loi cela alors que l'on
vient de voir arriver à quelques
ministres dans l'hémicycle notamment le
premier ministre
jean castex on va parler bien d'un autre
sujet un autre sujet très important est
bien celui de la proposition de
résolution qui porte sur la nécessité de
reconnaître la république du haut
karabakh le sénat va débattre de cette
proposition de résolution elle n'est pas
contraignante comme toute proposition de
réseau
sont rachetés mal mais c'est important
pour les parlementaires de se
positionner pour dire quoi
je pense que d'abord que le sénat prenne
cette position je pense une position
solennelle et je crois que le sénat en
france c'est ça va compter il y as nous
avons reçu les deux ambassadeurs d'abord
celle d'arménie depuis celui
d'intermédiaire il n'aura pu discuter
poser des questions ce qui est important
c'est à la fois la reconnaissance du
haut-karabakh la république parce que
c'est l'élément de pour protéger les
populations pour protéger l'état faire
en sorte qu' il ya une paix maintenant
durable
et puis je crois aussi dans la
résolution vous le verrez on dit qu
amendé des questions autour d'une
enquête un sauna sur d'éventuels crimes
de guerre et bas soit portée donc tout
ça est l'ambassadeur d'azerbaïdjan a dit
qu'il était prêt à coopérer donc je
crois qu'on peut imaginer que cela
puisse nous faire avancer
justement on va rejoindre la salle des
conférences alexandre puis sort car vous
êtes avec christian cambon le président
de la commission de la défense et des
affaires étrangères pour parler
justement de ce texte qui va être
débattu tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle
du sénat
eh oui christian cambon le message de
cette résolution qui va être examiné par
le sénat
c'est finalement de dire que la france a
été un peu une active sur ce conflit
haut karabagh le premier message est un
message de solidarité avec l'arménie
avec pays avec lequel nous avons quand
même des liens historiques particuliers
et la tragédie qui vient de frapper
l'arménie mérité que le sénat prenne une
initiative forte et c'est vrai que c'est
révolu cette résolution qui se
caractérise par le fait d'être porté par
la quasi-totalité des groupes toutes
sensibilités confondues
déjà c'est une procédure rare et le fait
qu'elle soit soutenue par la plupart des
groupes est un signe c'est un message
que nous envoyons effectivement à
l'exécutif car le groupe de minsk qui
depuis 20 ans s'occupe de cette affaire
du haut karabagh manifestement on ne
donne pas les résultats que l'on
attendait et donc l'idée c'est de
provoquer un peu le gouvernement pour
dire écoutez prenait les choses en main
on a quand même été assez humiliés par
les conditions du cessez le feu puisque
la france qui est coprésidente du groupe
n'a même pas été prévenus on l'a appris
par des agences de presse
donc c'est le moment de dire au
gouvernement passer à l'action
sur le plan humanitaire sur le plan du
règlement de ce conflit
et en souhaitant que la république du
haut karabakh soit reconnue c'est
effectivement des mots forts qui veut le
dire ce qu'ils veulent dire
mais alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé au
quai d'orsay à la diplomatie française
on a finalement s'est rangé derrière la
russie si on a laissé la russie gérer le
dossier basse et surtout la russie qui
nous a laissé mais je pense
personnellement sur ce sujet que notre
relation franco-russe qui avait pris un
bon départ depuis 2010 9 lorsque le
président de la république avait
souhaité une nouvelle relation avec la
russie le les entretiens de brégançon
avec une nouvelle architecture de
sécurité en europe
et puis tout ça on a l'impression que
c'est un petit peu parti en live alors
c'est peut-être l'effet du coronavirus
donc comme il va y avoir un vaccin c'est
le moment d'y aller
merci beaucoup question qu'en bon pour
votre réaction merci beaucoup alexandre
votre réaction marc philippe daubresse
la france n'a pas je soutiens évidemment
cette résolution et je me réjouis qu'à
l'exception du groupe en marche
tous les groupes soient unis pour pour
dire leur solidarité avec l'arménie et
pour expliquer qu'elle ait vraiment un
prêt problème voilà on a juste à côté à
voisin turc
monsieur erdogan qui est un qui lancent
des des assauts islamistes répété il
craint couloir il fait un coup de force
clairement sur le dos des arméniens hui
qu un couloir entre la turquie et les
délais territoire du nord et l'europe
excusez moi de dire reste quand même
pantoise moi j'ai participé que quand
j'étais au gouvernement un conseil des
ministres où on m'a dit vous avez de jeu
défendez la tva à taux réduit pour le
logement social et on me dit vous avez
deux minutes pour parler la turquie à 2
minutes pour parler et j pourquoi la
turquie à deux minutes
baala elle va peut-être entrer dans
l'europe ce qui désole mais elle n'est
pas dans l'europe et on voit bien qu'il
ya des gros problème là dessus et que
l'europe doit réagir quand l'essentiel
est en jeu et donc c'est important de
porter ce message et c'est important de
dire que la diplomatie française doit
aller maintenant plus loi pourrait
affirmer un certain nombre de choses
fondamentales contient eu la révolution
orange à kiev en ukraine on a quand même
su dire un certain nombre de choses il
faut pas avoir peur de le dire vous
savez moi je suis par le russe j'aime
beaucoup la civilisation slave
mais à un moment donné
la politique et la diplomatie doivent
dire des choses l'europe porte des
valeurs elle doit pas laisser faire
certaines choses
voilà un sujet d'accord en tout cas sur
ce plateau sur cette proposition de
résolution qui sera donc débattue après
les questions d'actualité et on va aller
une dernière fois salle des conférences
et on va rejoindre alexandre qui est
avec annick billon la présidente de la
délégation aux droits des femmes en ce
jour bien spéciale alexandre
effectivement journée internationale de
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
annick billon bonjour alors un an après
le grenelle en france contre les
violences faites aux femmes est ce qu on
a progressé dans la lutte contre ce
fléau
écouter le bilan est assez mitigé
aujourd'hui les chiffres sont toujours à
la hausse véritablement on a eu 100 46
femmes en 2020 en 2019 qui sont décédés
suite à des féminicides tuées par leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint
plus de deux cent mille femmes victimes
de violence donc non les chiffres
continuent de progresser et c'est très
inquiétant
je pense que là la réponse que nous
apportons aujourd'hui aux violences
faites aux femmes est assez incomplète
et pourtant le gouvernement a mis en
oeuvre toute une série de mesures comme
l'expérimentation du bracelet anti
rapprochement la levée du secret médical
en cas de danger imminent
ces mesures et non par elles n'ont pas
porté leurs fruits ces mesures à elles
sont arrivées les unes après les autres
il ya eu le grenelle il ya eu un certain
nombre de propositions loi il ya eu un
projet de loi hélas toutes ces mesures
mises bout à bout elles ne sont pas
suffisantes elles ne sont pas
suffisantes pourquoi parce que déjà nous
n'avons pas un grand projet de loi qui
balaierait tous les angles morts qui
dresseraient aussi un état des lieux de
ce qui existe et nous n'avons pas non
plus les crédits en espagne par exemple
la loi cadre en 2004 elle a été
accompagnée d'un milliard d'euros 1
milliard d'euros en france le budget
contre les violences faites aux femmes
c'est 41 millions d'euros
on peut pas arriver au même résultat
donc il ya un véritable problème
financier
il ya aussi le problème de la crise du
coronavirus du confinement qui a
entraîné aussi une flambée de ces
violences tout à fait la délégation aux
droits que je préside a travaillé
d'ailleurs pendant plusieurs mois sur ce
sujet là les femmes et les enfants qui
étaient confinés c'était un confinement
sans fin en réalité ça évidemment
multiplier
le risque de maltraitance de violences
au sein des couples mais ce n'est pas la
seule explication
l'explication aussi c'est que nous avons
des défaillances notamment au niveau de
la chaîne pénale
aujourd'hui la chaîne pénale il y à des
défaillances 80 % des plaintes sont
classées sans suite
il y a des choses à faire la délégation
a d'ailleurs proposé que le week-end il
y une permanence des juges aux affaires
sociales comme c'est le cas pour les
procureurs d'accord il ya également la
question des enfants je voulais vous
interroger sur et bien ces enfants qui
sont témoins de vieux de ces violences
conjugales il faut les protéger
davantage les viols les enfants ils sont
toujours des victimes ce sont des
victimes qu'ils subissent les violences
ou qu'ils y assistent
donc il ya un sujet qui est le ski sont
les enfants
aujourd'hui il faut absolument comme je
les dis qu'on prenne le problème dans sa
globalité une loi-cadre comme ça a été
fait en espagne et qu'on balaye tous les
sujets il n'y a pas que les violences il
y a tous les sujets merci beaucoup à un
aiguillon pour votre intervention et on
va aller tout de suite dans la tribune
de presse de l'hémicycle du sénat avec
vous mr s'amarrer pierre bourgeois pour
voir un peu le programme de ces
questions d'actualité oui alexandrins ça
va peut-être un petit peu tanguay
aujourd'hui dans ces questions
d'actualité marlène schiappa la ministre
déléguée à la citoyenneté 1 va devoir
répondre aux questions des sénateurs
d'abord sur les inquiétudes autour du
projet de loi sécurité globale beaucoup
s'inquiètent
ici au sénat de la limitation des images
des forces de l'ordre une atteinte à la
liberté d'informer un estime le groupe
écologiste et le groupe socialiste
marlène schiappa va aussi devoir
s'expliquer sur l'évacuation musclée un
du camp de migrants place de la
république à paris lundi dernier
beaucoup d'inquiétude également au sénat
sur les conséquences de la crise
économique liée aux convives les
sénateurs 13 une explosion de la
précarité
au gouvernement on ne sauve retransmis
en direct sur public sénat sur notre
site internet au nom du bureau du sénat
j'appelle chacun de vous a observé une
valeur essentielle le respect des uns et
des autres mais aussi le respect du
temps de parole je donne la parole à
notre collègue emmanuel capus pour le
groupe les indépendants république et
territoires et il a deux minutes
merci monsieur le président le président
de la république a annoncé hier un plan
d' assouplissement progressif du
confinement
ce plan a le mérite de donner de la
visibilité aux français je salue ici la
réouverture dès ce week-end de tous les
commerces
c'était une décision extrêmement attendu
sur ses banques
je salue aussi la levée annoncé du
confinement si la situation le permet et
la réouverture des cinémas des théâtres
des musées de tout ce qui fait la vie et
nous permet l'accès est essentielle à la
culture le report au 20 janvier de la
réouverture des bars et des restaurants
c'est en revanche une nouvelle difficile
et il conviendra monsieur le ministre
d'accompagner ces secteurs sinistrés à
la hauteur exacte de leur préjudice
j'ai aussi une pensée pour les étudiants
et les jeunes qui ne pourront pas
retrouver leur établissement avant
février
pour eux le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que la lumière est encore faible
au bout du tunnel
mais ces annonces indispensable pose un
certain nombre de questions qui
appellent des précisions pour être sûr
qu'elle soit acceptée par les français
à combien par exemple les français
pourront-ils se réunir à noël et au
réveillon pour profiter de leurs
familles et de leurs proches sans
risquer de nouveau cluster quand finira
le couvre-feu qui est annoncée pour le
15 décembre
doit-on comprendre monsieur le ministre
qu'il prendra fin le 20 janvier date à
laquelle les bars et les restaurants
vont réouvrir parce que sinon le
préjudice pour les restaurants va encore
être augmentée et enfin pour les cultes
la jauge des 30 est difficilement
compréhensible dans des cathédrales ou
des églises souvent très vaste et
parfois immenses cette jauge ne
doit-elle pas disparaître au plus tard
au 15 décembre et en tout cas avant noël
au moment où les cinémas et les théâtres
seront ouverts sans autres limites que
les protocoles sanitaires
il en va monsieur le ministre de
l'acceptabilité de ces mesures
pour vous répondre la parole et que
monsieur le secrétaire d'état auprès du
premier ministre porte parole du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur qui a pu vous l'avez dit le
président de la république s'est exprimé
hier soir parce qu'il avait donné rendez
vous aux français autour du 1er décembre
après avoir annoncé le confinement pour
le mois de novembre
nous sommes à un tournant dans
l'épidémie puisque le nombre de
contaminations constater chaque jour
diminue puisque le nombre d'entrées en
réanimation à l'hôpital diminuent et que
donc les efforts qui ont été consentis
par les français depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines paye et je pense que
nous devons collectivement nous en
réjouir et pour autant il ne faut pas
baisser la garde
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président de la république a annoncé que
le confinement allait se poursuivre
jusqu'au 15 décembre avec des règles
restrictives parce que nous ne pouvons
pas laisser un risque que l'épidémie
repartent et connaissent une nouvelle
flambée comme elle en a connu partout en
europe depuis plusieurs semaines un
calendrier a été donné avec des étapes
claires moi je vous rejoins et nous vous
rejoignons sur le fait que les français
avaient besoin de cette visibilité elle
est au rendez vous trois étapes ont été
annoncés avec des objectifs sanitaires
en termes d'indicateurs extrêmement
clair qu'ils sont partagés et qui seront
nécessaires de d'obtenir et de
stabiliser pour franchir les étapes les
unes après les autres
à partir de là vous avez posé trois
questions précises je vais essayer d'y
répondre le mieux possible vous avez
demandé 6 au 15 décembre
le confinement allait se poursuivre ou
non là dessus les choses sont claires si
la situation sanitaire continue à
s'améliorer et que 15 décembre
nous avons atteint les cibles qui ont
été fixés à savoir notamment 5000
contamination par jour et un nombre
réduit en réanimation alors le
confinement sera levé il ne s'agit pas
de dire qu'il n'y aura plus de contrat
c'est un couvre-feu prendra le relais
deuxième question sur noël
comment est ce que les français pourront
fêter noël le président l'a dit lui même
ça ne sera pas un noël comme un autre
mais nous donnons la possibilité aux
français parce que c'est une fête
importante pour les familles de fêter
noël et le premier ministre aura
l'occasion de s'exprimer demain dans une
conférence de presse pour donner
davantage de précisions tout comme sur
la question à des cultes que vous avez
évoqué la parole est maintenant notre
collègue philippe dallier pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci mais je kg en ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur mais il n'est pas là le 17
novembre dernier à saint denis dans mon
département
un campement sauvage de migrants de plus
de 2500 personnes a été évacué afin de
réaliser ce que l'on appelle pudiquement
une mise à l'abri
pour ce faire les services de l'état ont
procédé comme ils le font d'ordinaire
c'est à dire qu'ils ont réquisitionner
des gymnases cette fois ci c'était dans
le val de marne
c'est parfois à paris dans les hauts de
seine ou en seine saint denis des
nuitées d'hôtel ont été réservées
également et les associations ont été
mobilisés
quelques jours plus tard près de 400
personnes issues nous dit on de ce camp
se sont retrouvés place de la république
et ont été dispersées dans les
conditions qu'on sait
force nous est donc de constater que
malgré des moyens budgétaires toujours
plus important pour ouvrir des places de
cada pour essayer d'instruire les
dossiers plus rapidement mais aussi 400
millions d'euros supplémentaires sur
l'hébergement d'urgence en 2020 nous
sommes toujours dépassé par la situation
ce qui n'est pas humainement acceptable
et ce qui l'est surtout supposer que le
flux de migrants continuent à progresser
fortement alors même que la situation
sanitaire limite les déplacements
alors madame la ministre vous allez me
répondre à ma question est simple
avez vous les moyens de la politique de
gestion des flux migratoires que le
gouvernement affiche car voyez-vous
plutôt qu'en matière de politique j'y
vois plutôt là la vieille technique du
sapeur camember on ferme un camp de
migrants souverain qu'en 2100
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué en charge de la
citoyenneté au nabot schiappa merci
monsieur le président mesdames mais les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je voudrais vous
dire qu'effectivement il y avait dans un
premier temps des migrants qui était
installé en seine saint denis et qui
ensuite ont été prises en charge pour
certains d'entre eux par les services de
l'état pour être mis à l'abris
effectivement et pour être hébergées et
d'autres ont été redirigés par des
associations et se sont retrouvés
ensuite à plus nombreux sur la place de
la république et donc nous avons décidé
effectivement une opération d'évacuation
de ce camp de migrants avec s'étendre
puisque cette occupation est est
illégale et ensuite une mise à l'abri
immédiate a été opéré pour loger ces
personnes vous avez évoqué effectivement
l'augmentation des moyens du
gouvernement et je vous en remercie pour
réduire les délais de réponse aux
demandeurs d'asile et je peux vous
confirmer que ce sont 200 personnes
supplémentaires qui ont été recrutés par
l'eau fera pour effectivement étudié
plus rapidement les dossiers et répondre
plus rapidement
oui ou non aux demandes qui sont
formulées mais je vais vous dire les
choses telles que je les pense monsieur
le sénateur et je sais que nous ne
serons pas d'accord mais c'est aussi
peut-être ça la politique et la
démocratie
oui nous assumons que l'état finance de
la mise à l'abri et de l'hébergement des
personnes qui sont venus en france pour
chercher une vie meilleure et non nous
n'allons pas nous excuser de le faire la
parole est à monsieur d'allier
même la ministre je ne m'attendais pas
être accusé de cela mais enfin peu
importe si vous aviez les moyens de
votre politique
les délais d'instruction en cada serait
de quelques mois ils sont toujours de
près d'un an
si vous aviez les moyens de votre
politique sow qui a obtenu l'asile
aurait une situation de logement et ont
reconduit rey à la frontière ceux qui
sont déboutés du droit d'asile
ce qui éviterait d'ambo lisez le système
si vous aviez les moyens de votre
politique les centres d'hébergement
d'urgence
effectivement ne serait pas pour
beaucoup majoritairement acquis à
accueillir des gens qui sont en
situation irrégulière que nous ne savons
pas traitées alors madame la ministre
la réponse à ma question malheureusement
c'est non la situation est de plus en
plus graves sur ce sujet merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à la fois collègue olivier
henno pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues
au lendemain du premier jour de la
campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur et
des autres associations caritatives
nous avons le devoir moral d'aborder
avec gravité lucidité les signaux
alarmants d'une montée de la précarité
de la pauvreté une augmentation des
aides alimentaires de 50%
la multiplication du nombre de jeunes
parmi les demandeurs la moitié de
personnes accueillies aux restos du
coeur ont moins de 25 ans ainsi je vois
dans mon département du nord des
étudiants qui sautent volontairement des
reports c'est terrible je suis
interpellé par des intermittents de la
restauration ou des saisonniers qui sont
en train de tomber dans la misère
nous faisons face en fait à un risque de
basculement dans l'extrême précarité de
personnes qui ne pensait jamais devoir
faire appel aux aides sociales
cette crise sanitaire ne doit pas nous
voiler la face sur la crise économique
et surtout sociale qui se trouve à nos
portes
la bonne réponse à cette crise ne sera
ni technocratique ni verticale
la bonne réponse ne viendra pas d'une
attente d'un éventuel russe allemand la
bonne réponse elle ne peut venir que du
terrain des élus locaux des partenaires
sociaux et surtout du secteur associatif
mobilisés sur toutes les grandes causes
sociales et humaines pauvreté
l'inégalité des chances injustices dans
les quartiers le secteur associatif est
mobilisé certes mais aussi fragile
presqu'à bout
il mérite toute notre attention
l'expérience nous a appris qu'une
association qui meurt est une
association qui disparaît pour toujours
alors madame la ministre
ma question est toute simple quelle est
la stratégie sociale du gouvernement
quelles mesures spécifiques pour faire
face à cette précarité nouvelles et
surtout à quand un véritable plan de
cohésion sociale qui mobilise tous les
acteurs de terrain je vous remercie pour
nous rendre la parole est calviniste
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur olivier henno votre question me
permets de rappeler que la crise humaine
n'a pas démarré et la pauvreté
avec la crise sanitaire vous le savez
mieux que quiconque vous êtes du même
département que le mien de la même
région et nous le savons chacun le
gouvernement a agi depuis le début du
quinquennat pour accompagner les
compatriotes
confronté à des difficultés ce n'est ni
une fatalité ni une assignation depuis
2010 est ce sont plus de 17 milliards
d'euros qui ont été mobilisés mais nous
avons mis l'accent sur l'apprentissage
sur l'insertion sociale et
professionnelle et cela me tient
particulièrement à coeur et sur
l'accompagnement des personnes éloignées
de l'emploi
le département du nord d'ailleurs
mobilisera deux mille personnes suivies
pour vers les métiers du grand âge très
prochainement je vais les rencontrer à
ce sujet je trouve que c'est une
approche plus émancipatrice plus humaine
plus sociale qui vise à sortir les
personnes de la précarité et non les a
signés ces résultats par ton se heurte à
la dureté de la crise sanitaire et nous
le savons et les vulnérabilités dans ces
moments-là s'accroissent c'est pourquoi
les bénéficiaires du rsa de la ss les
étudiants bourses et les jeunes
disposant des apl se verront verser dans
les prochains jours 150 euros d'ailleurs
en fin de semaine avec un versement
majoré de 100 euros par enfant pour plus
de 4 millions de foyers
des dizaines de millions d'euros ont été
mobilisés pour assurer la mise à l'abri
la distribution de masques ou une
activité l'accès à un emploi une
activité adaptée
je pense aussi aux 6,5 milliards d'euros
mobilisés pour le plan un jeune une
solution par la formation l'insertion l'
embauche comme l'a annoncé le président
de la république
les premiers résultats sont
encourageants olivier ferrand a annoncé
hier un plan de soutien aux associations
donc que vous évoquez de aux
associations de 100 millions d'euros
pour mieux accompagner les plus
précaires face à la crise
en développant des actions innovantes en
accompagnant la transformation des
infrastructures des associations ce
budget viendra en complément aux six des
94 millions d'euros alloués aux
associations de l'aide alimentaire que
vous évoquez
sur la seule année 2000 20 alors vous le
voyez monsieur le sénateur le
gouvernement adapte sa réponse à la
hauteur de la crise qui nous touche de
plein fouet personne ne sera laissé au
bout du chemin que leur bord du chemin
et nous serons tous associés monsieur
vidéo oui merci madame la ministre votre
réponse mais le pays n'attend pas un
empilement de mesures
il attend une réponse humaine voilà
pourquoi notre groupe souhaite un
véritable plan de cohésion sociale qui
mobilise tous les acteurs de terrain je
vous remercie
merci la parole et notre collègue
marie-claude mariage pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes avaient la parole monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le 25
novembre marque chaque année la journée
internationale pour l'élimination des
violences à l'égard des femmes salariées
indispensable mères de familles épuisées
femmes précarisées les premières de
corvée n'auront pas été épargné par la
crise sanitaire en cours d'autant moins
avec le regain de violences
intrafamiliales engendrés par les
confinements successifs tous les deux
jours une femme est tuée par son
conjoint ou son ex conjointe et nous
constatons cette année + 10 16% de
violences conjugales constaté durant
l'année 2019 les faits sont pressés
d'une grande brutalité les moyennes
doivent l'être également ceux promis
suite au grenelle
il y a un an ne sont pas à la hauteur
pire une dégradation de la qualité
d'écouté des victimes est aujourd'hui à
craindre avec la mise en concurrence de
la plateforme 39 19 la fédération
nationale solidarité femmes doit
poursuivre sa mission son travail de
qualité a toujours fait ses preuves est
aujourd'hui plus que jamais les annonces
chiffrées d'augmentation des places
d'hébergement que des associations
spécialisées ont pourtant bien du mal à
comptabiliser ne peuvent pas non plus
faire l'économie d'une qualité de prise
en charge un lit et un toit ça ne suffit
pas il faut accompagner social un
accompagnement social de ces femmes dans
la plus grande précarité humaine et un
accompagnement qui passe aussi par une
véritable politique de prévention dans
l'éducation nationale
une prise en charge adaptée dans nos
commissariats avec une police formé une
loi-cadre doit être adopté et des
tribunaux spécialisés érigé sur le
modèle de nos voisins espagnols
exemplaires sur le sujet oui pas moins
d'un milliard est nécessaire pour la
salle lutte contre les violences faites
aux femmes
aussi monsieur le ministre comment
comptez vous redresser les moyens
financiers et humains pour lutter enfin
efficacement et durablement contre ce
fléau de violences faites aux femmes
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
secrétaires d'état porte-parole du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice mariage vous pris d'abord
d'excuser l'absence de ma collègue
elisabeth moreno qui se trouve
actuellement justement en déplacement
avec le président de la république pour
visiter un centre d'hébergement de
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
puisque vous l'avez dit nous sommes
aujourd'hui en ce 25 novembre à la
journée internationale pour
l'élimination de la violence à l'égard
des femmes
et vous avez à raison rappeler la
réalité terrible dans le monde mais dans
notre pays en particulier et ces
chiffres que vous avez évoquées qui nous
indigne toutes et tous c'est la raison
pour laquelle dès le début de ce
quinquennat le président de la
république a décidé d'en faire une
grande cause nationale le 25 novembre
nous affichons une ambition le 25
novembre 2019 nous concluions un
grenelle contre les violences faites aux
femmes historique et je veux d'ailleurs
salué l'implication de marlène schiappa
qui était à l'époque chargé de ces
questions là au gouvernement et qui les
poursuit au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur aujourd'hui à l'occasion de
ce 25 novembre 2020 nous pouvons faire
un bilan des actions qui ont été
engagées à l'issue de ce grenelle et il
y a des résultats parce qu'il ya une
politique massive qui a été engagée nous
avons renforcé les moyens
nous développons le bracelet anti
rapprochement se développe qui se
développe partout en france nous avons
créé cette année 1000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence supplémentaires
il y en aura mille autres
supplémentaires ce qui fait que fin 2021
7700 places dédiées aux femmes victimes
de violence seront opérationnels nous
continuer à augmenter les buttes les
budgets une augmentation historique de
40% du budget de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes
t out et j'entends votre appel à une loi
cadre il ya eu madame la sénatrice trois
lois qui ont été votées ces trois
dernières années la responsabilité qui
est la nôtre notre l'exécutif est aussi
évidemment des acteurs dans les
territoires c'est d'appliquer les
mesures qui ont été adoptées qui ont été
votées et nous sommes extrêmement
sensibles parce que l'explication soit
faite c'est la responsabilité de ma
collègue elisabeth montreynaud et je
sais que nous pourrons continuer à
avancer ensemble autour de cet enjeu qui
je crois nous rassemble toutes et tous
merci la parole et notre collègue marie
evrard pour le gros du rassemblement
démocrate progressiste et indépendant
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
déléguée auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur en charge la citoyenneté
en cette journée internationale pour
l'élimination de la violence à l'égard
des femmes je voudrais avoir une pensée
très appuyé pour les femmes de ce monde
victimes de maltraitance au quotidien
les mesures de confinement mis en oeuvre
dans plusieurs pays ont rappelé la
réalité tragique que peut revêtir pour
certaines femmes le huit clos familial
les données publiées par l'onu en
septembre parle d'elle-même
le confinement a fait augmenter les
pleins de 30% en france
la france qui a porté un grenelle
ambitieux réunissant pendant plusieurs
mois les associations les acteurs de
terrain et l'ensemble des
administrations
la france qui a décliné par deux textes
de lois notamment les mesures proposées
par ces travaux et dont la mise en
oeuvre a récemment fait l'objet d'un
bilan d'étape
je veux saluer les acteurs de terrain
qui rendent possible cette action et
plus spécifiquement la mémoire d'alina
kraton qui était directrice déléguée
départementale aux droits des femmes et
à l'égalité dans l'yonne et qui a
apporté sans relâche sa réflexion et son
action je veux également salué les
forces de sécurité intérieures elles
sont à nos interlocuteurs clés et
parfois premier pour les victimes de
violences conjugales les appels d'
initiative réalisée par
les policiers et les gendarmes pendant
le premier confinement l'ont bien
illustrer cette action des forces de
sécurité justement parce qu'elle peut
tout changer ne peut se penser sans une
vraie formation
la notion d'emprise introduite dans la
loi cet été
exprime bien la complexité des
mécanismes en jeu
madame la ministre pouvez vous préciser
les mesures prises et envisagé pour
renforcer cette formation tant à titre
initial que tout au long de la carrière
merci en seulement votre première prise
de parole dans cet hémicycle pas chers
collègues je vais donner la parole aux
milices délégué en charge de la
citoyenneté pour vous répondre
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice marie et voir
d'abord je voudrais commencer par saluer
votre engagement en la matière et le
travail que vous menez dans l'yonne et
qui est extrêmement important pour
protéger les femmes face aux violences
conjugales et face à toutes les victimes
y compris avec monsieur ministre jean
baptiste lemoyne
je voudrais répondre à votre question et
vous dire madame la sénatrice que
l'engagement du ministère de l'intérieur
est totale les 290 1000 femmes et hommes
qui travaillent dans ce ministère
s'engage pour mieux protéger les femmes
c'est le sens du point d'étape que nous
avons fait ce matin avec le directeur
général de la police nationale le
directeur général de la gendarmerie
nationale et les responsables des
groupes de travail du grenelle des
violences conjugales pour le ministère
de l'intérieur
depuis ce grenelle et la mobilisation
collective du gouvernement de nombreuses
mesures ont été mises en place pour
faciliter l'accès des femmes au dépôt de
plainte
je pense à la grille d'évaluation du
danger construite avec les associations
à la roue des violences je pense à la
possibilité pour les femmes de déposer
plainte sans se rendre dans un
commissariat ou une gendarmerie via la
plateforme arrêtons les violences point
gouv.fr où je me suis rendu avec mes
collègues
elisabeth moreno et adrien attaqué la
semaine dernière et vous les policiers
des gendarmes formés répondent à ces
femmes vous m'interrogez sur la
formation et je voudrais vous dire
qu'elle est fondamental pour nous nous
avons créé 120 heures de formation
initiale pour les policiers les
gendarmes pour mieux prendre en charge
les femmes victimes de violences
sexistes et sexuelles et violences
conjugales nous ajoutons à cela des
formations continues
et la création d'un book avec
l'initiative citoyenne et point org
organisé avec l'association le collectif
féministe contre le viol pour mieux
former de manière continue l'ensemble
des policiers et l'ensemble des
gendarmes
je voudrais vous dire les choses très
simplement madame la sénatrice la chaîne
pénale est fondamentale et le travail
avec le ministère le garde des sceaux
avec dupont moretti est très étroit au
ministère de l'intérieur et avec gérald
darmanin notre objectif
il est simple que 100 % des plaintes
soient prises que 100 % des plaintes
soient bien qualifiés et que 100 % des
plaintes soient transmises au parquet
pour qu'elle puisse être traité et que
ces femmes puissent être sauvés et
protégés je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
jérôme durain pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre jamais
deux sans trois voilà ce qu'a dit un
policier mardi soir sur la place de la
république avant de s'attaquer pour la
troisième fois un journaliste jamais
deux sans trois c'est ce que semble dire
monsieur l'allemand qui après
l'évacuation du pont de sully en juin
2019 avait demandé un rapport ce
monsieur l'allemand qui après la
répression d'une manifestation déjà
place de la république en mars 2020
avait demandé un rapport et ce même
monsieur l'allemand qui a produit un
rapport après les incidents de mardi
le contenu de ce rapport nous ne le
connaissons pas mais il a amené monsieur
darmanin demandé un autre rapport à
l'igpn celui là nous sommes impatients
de lire tout cela mais au fond le seul
rapport qui nous intéresse celui qu'il
faut changer c'est le rapport de la
police de la république avec ses
citoyens nous ne nous accommodons pas de
la formule du préfet l'allemand nous ne
sommes pas dans le même camp madame
votre gouvernement prétend protéger
policiers et gendarmes
mais c'est lui qui les exposent en
continuant de creuser le fossé
d'alimenter la défiance voulait pousser
à la faute
vous voulez une police qui sert le
pouvoir nous voulons une police de la
république
les violences de la place de la
république constitue le point d'orgue
d'une longue série de dérives monsieur
castex vous l'avez compris puisque vous
annoncé vouloir saisir le conseil
constitutionnel sur l'article 24
en attendant les rapports allez vous
siffler la fin de la partie
comment surtout comptez-vous recoudre le
lien entre forces de l'ordre et citoyen
quelles consignes allez-vous donner à
monsieur l'allemand pour que la
manifestation prévue samedi
paris ne donne pas lieu à de nouveaux
débordements pour vous répondre
la parole est plombée nice délégué
chargé de la citoyenneté vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur durant je vais vous
répondre sur le fond mais d'abord je
voudrais vous dire que je ne crois pas
que quelques actions isolées doivent
nous permettre de jeter l'opprobre sur
l'ensemble de la police de la république
qui mène dans son ensemble un travail
sérieux important primordial et qui
permet de maintenir l'ordre républicain
parce que l'ordre républicain c'est
l'ordre qui nous protège de l'ordre des
clans et donc je crois que notre rôle de
responsable public de responsables
politiques
c'est aussi de protéger ce qui nous
protège et de défendre l'action résolue
menée par la police que s'est il passé
en l'occurrence sur la place de la
république
vous aviez là un campement installé de
manière illégale organisée avec des
tentes et avec à l'intérieur de ses
tantes des personnes des migrants que
nous avons souhaité pouvoir mettre à
l'abri et pouvoir héberger comme je le
disais juste à l'instant
alors que s'est-il passé dès le
lendemain matin le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin
immédiatement en voyant les images qu'il
a lui-même qualifié de choquant à
souhaitez commander un rapport au
précèdent police et à la suite du
rapport remis par le préfet de police
qui recommandait de saisir l'igpn est
bien le ministre de l'intérieur
conformément au souhait émis dans ce
rapport a souhaité saisir l'igpn ce qui
est un acte important il a indiqué qu'il
en tirerait toutes les conséquences et
qu'il rendrait son rapport public dans
les 48 heures c'est à dire maintenant
dans un peu plus de vingt quatre heures
ensuite sur le fond du sujet car il ya
un fond du sujet l'hébergement de ces
personnes oui les migrants sont des
personnes qui doivent être traités avec
humanité avec fraternité et c'est
pourquoi là aussi des lendemain matin
avec ma collègue emmanuelle wargon
ministre du logement
nous avons souhaité mobiliser les
administration pour sauver des trouver
les situations de relogement pour ses
hébergements
nous avons présenté publiquement un
premier point d'étape et dès demain
emmanuelle wargon la mise au logement et
moi même nous recevrons l'ensemble des
associations qui travaillent dans ce
champ pour partager avec elles les
solutions proposées par l'état pour
reloger très simplement ces migrants
vous le voyez nous apportant des
réponses nous travaillons sur le fond et
nous sommes pleinement mobilisés pour le
respect des lois mais aussi pour le
respect de la dignité humaine et pour la
valeur de fraternité qui est une valeur
importante dans notre république je vous
remercie monsieur durand
merci de 7 de son moral madame la
ministre nous aimons les policiers de la
république nous aimons les policiers la
république quand ils sont au milieu de
la population
nous aimons les policiers de la
république quand ils sont bien utilisés
qui ne sont pas prisonniers de
l'ambition d'un homme qui cherche
toujours en faire un peu plus
et d'ailleurs je ne suis pas certain que
vous arriviez à convaincre dans vos
propres rangs de la légitimité de la
ponte que vous êtes en train de prendre
on a bien compris une chose en tout cas
c'est qu'en matière de sécurité publique
et de libertés publiques
le maquereau nisme n'a qu'une mince et
une main droite
merci la parole et à madame maryse carré
pour leur groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président d'arm à
question s'adresse à l'origine à madame
la ministre du travail de l'emploi et de
l'insertion
monsieur le ministre nul besoin de
revenir sur les difficultés que nous
traversons et contre lesquels l'ensemble
des français luttent depuis le mois de
mars
mais je souhaitais aujourd'hui vous
alerter sur des professions qui vont
rester sur le bord du chemin
les premiers sont des réceptionnistes
des veilleurs de nuit des femmes de
ménage des maîtres d'hôtel des extras
tous ses salariés de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration dans les emplois sont au
rythme des saisons et de l'activité
touristique dans mon département et
notamment à lourdes
ils sont des centaines sur le fil de
leur fin de droits au chômage parce
qu'ils n'ont pu re signer leur contrat
au mois de mars dernier
les seconds sont les pisteurs
secouristes des dameurs des moniteurs de
ski suspendu aujourd'hui à la
réouverture des stations de sports pour
noël on les appelle les saisonniers à
lourdes on les appelle aujourd'hui les
oublier et ils sont le maillon essentiel
de notre économie touristique et de
montagne ils ont tous comme nous hier
soir entendu le président la république
et je le cite les saisonniers les extras
qui n'ont plus d'engagement depuis le
mois de mars trouveront une réponse
exceptionnelle à leur situation
aussi monsieur ministre entre les
milliers de saisonniers qui n'ont pu
retrouver une activité qui arrivent en
fin de droits et ceux qui ne
retrouveront une activité au mieux qu'en
janvier
quelle réponse d'urgence comptez vous
apporter pour traduire les engagements
du président de la république
les saisonniers ont ils droit à une
recharge automatique de leurs droits
afin de survivre dans une situation qui
risque d'être durable et je pense
notamment à mon département où la crise
sociale sera sans précédent
monsieur le ministre l'état localement à
activer les leviers possibles
ils ne seront pas suffisants il nous
faut une réponse il leur faut une
réponse urgente aujourd'hui et elle est
entre vos mains
ma question est donc simple pouvez vous
nous préciser les dispositifs dead qui
seront donc ils seront proposés et ainsi
donner une lueur d'espoir à ceux qui en
l'état actuel des mesures passeront au
travers des mailles du filet de la
solidarité nationale je vous remercie
vous reprendre la parole étaleront les
troisièmes ski secrétaire d'état en
charge des retraites la santé au travail
chez ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure les
propos du président de la république
dans son allocution d'hier soir et vous
avez raison de préciser qu' il a évoqué
la situation des saisonniers des extras
des réceptionnistes tous ces français et
françaises qui font partie de ces
saisonniers que vous avez évoqué que
vous connaissez bien dans votre
territoire et vous avez effectivement
entendu qu'ils trouveront une réponse
exceptionnelle à leur situation je
voudrais revenir sur quelques éléments
eau qui coule concerne à la fois cercle
et jean votre région des hautes pyrénées
de lourdes mais aussi et sans aucun
doute de nombreux autres français et
françaises qui sont concernés par cela
d'abord avec les partenaires sociaux
vous le savez lisabeth bornes la
ministre du travail est mobilisé pour
protéger tous les travailleurs qui ont
vu leur activité se réduire voire
disparaître du fait de la crise
l'ampleur d'ailleurs de la crise c'est
vrai est particulièrement forte dans les
zones que vous connaissez bien est
particulièrement forte aussi pour les
dimensions des saisonniers dans les
hôtels cafés restaurants vous dire
d'ailleurs que le dispositif d'activité
partielle que nous mobilisons sur sept
années 2020 au titre de la crise
sanitaire
un dispositif de plus de 30 milliards
bénéficient déjà auteur de 3 milliards
pour l'ensemble des salariés des hôtels
cafés restaurants
enfin je voudrais aussi vous dire parce
que j'ai été partiellement attentif à
votre question et à la situation
notamment qu'il ya sur lourdes et donc
nous avons pris les contacts avec
l'ensemble des correspondants de pôle
emploi sur sept sur ce site je peux déjà
vous dire que sur les saisonniers
qui sont identifiés à l'ours sur 125
saisonniers qui avait été identifié à
pôle emploi qui arrivait au terme de
leurs droits se sont vus déjà proposé ou
des emplois dans la vallée où des
solutions en matière de formation pour
plus de 60 d'entre certes cela ne répond
pas à tous et vous avez souligné
l'importance eux d'avoir une réponse
globale alors pour cela je voudrais vous
dire madame la sénatrice vous le savez
que le travail du gouvernement se
poursuit sur ce sujet dans la continuité
du comité interministériel du tourisme
avec jean-baptiste lemoyne et les élus
du territoire dont vous faites partie
nous allons donc trouver les solutions
les plus adaptées que vous attendez
d'ici je crois quelques heures quelques
jours
merci la parole est à notre collègue
le président guillaume gontard pour le
groupe écologie solidarité territoire
vous avez la parole merci merci monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre le gouvernement se fait le
héraut de la défense des valeurs
républicaines
nous avons encore constater toute la
puissance de vos propos lundi soir place
de la république à paris
la république sont aurait ainsi à mettre
des migrants à la rue et a déchiré leurs
tentes
la république sonne aurait ainsi à ta
base et les journalistes et a violenté
des avocats et des élus la république
son engrais ainsi aller ces femmes
hommes enfants se noyait en méditerranée
ou à les enfermer en centre de rétention
dans des conditions indignes
la république ça n'aurait ainsi à
renvoyer errer dans les vallées alpines
femmes enceintes et familles puis
attaquer en justice ceux qui tentent de
les aider
la république ça n'aurait ainsi à voter
des lois sécuritaires en planète à
d'urgence alors que le droit à
manifester et contraint la république ça
n'aurait ainsi à renier la liberté de la
presse et la liberté d'informer alors
monsieur le premier ministre la dérive
sécuritaire de votre gouvernement est
alarmante
le problème n'est pas l'action et les
révoltant de quelques fonctionnaires de
police isolé non le problème ces votes
loi asile et migrations et les lois
sécuritaires qui s'enchaînent et nous
enchaîne le problème c'est la doctrine
de maintien de l'ordre qui multiplie les
manifestants le problème ce qui mutilent
les manifestants pardon le problème
c'est la chaîne de commandement
comment le préfet l'allemand peut-il
encore être en poste après tant de
bavure et tant de propos honteux comment
le ministre de l'intérieur peut-il
continuer impunément à jeter de l'huile
sur le feu en permanence
monsieur le premier ministre quand allez
vous enfin prendre vos responsabilités
revoir votre politique migratoire et
sécuritaire déshumanisé et cesser de
courir enfin après l'extrême droite pour
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président le gouvernement
que j'ai l'honneur de conduire et la
majorité qui le soutient au parlement
conduis je vous le dis une politique
profondément républicaines la république
monsieur le sénateur s'est d'abord
assurer la sécurité de nos concitoyens
c'est respecter par tous les lois et les
règles de la république
c'est à dire celle là même qui sont
édictées par la représentation nationale
que s'est il passé l'autre soir et vous
le savez toutes et tous une
manifestation non déclarée
une occupation illégale du domaine
public
il était parfaitement normal que des
fonctionnaires de la république fasse
appliquer les lois de la république
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président à l'occasion de
ces événements des faits se sont
produits qui ont choqué et qui ont
appelé la mise en oeuvre des procédures
prévues par les lois de la république et
le gouvernement que je dirige veillera à
l'application de ces procédures
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale
danser le rôle a été saisie pour faire
la lumière sur ces faits le ministre de
l'intérieur à ma demande s'est engagé à
rendre public ce rapport et nous
tirerons les conséquences de ces
enseignements s est ce en quoi que ce
soit une raison pour jeter l'opprobre
sur les forces de sécurité de la
république à nos quinquas en aucun cas
les forces de sécurité de la république
qui doivent respecter elles mêmes les
lois de la république font un travail
difficile qui mérite l'hommage de
l'ensemble de cette assemblée
[Applaudissements]
et je ne peux pas davantage et je ne
peux pas davantage vous laisser dire que
ce gouvernement cherche en quoi que ce
soit à porter atteinte aux libertés
publiques garanties par les lois de la
république
c'est totalement inexact la loi le plat
proposition de loi qui va arriver dans
cette assemblée monsieur le président
d'id de sécurité globale est une
excellente loi elle vise elle vise elle
vise à renforcer la coordination des
forces de sécurité à mieux établir
encore l'intervention des polices
municipales dois je vous rappeler le
rôle qu'elles ont eu notamment lors du
dernier attentat de nice elle vise elle
vise également à encadrer l'intervention
d'un sécurité privée et à protéger nos
forces de sécurité et l'article 24
danger les 10 hier à l'assemblée je ne
doute pas que le sénat l'examinera dans
un souci de le clarifier n'a pas d'autre
but
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
de protéger les forces de sécurité s'en
porter en quoi que ce soit atteinte à la
liberté
sacré de la presse et la liberté
d'expression
lisez lisez ce texte est pas tous les
commentaires erronés qui en sont faits
plus que jamais plus que jamais la
liberté la sécurité sont des valeurs au
coeur de la république que ce
gouvernement défendra et défendra
toujours
sur le président gontard monsieur le
premier ministre à bruz la république
c'est l'état de droit et c'est votre
responsabilité
la république c'est la liberté l'égalité
et la fraternité
c'est la liberté d'informer c'est
l'égalité devant la loi des auteurs de
violences qu'ils soient policiers ou
manifestants
c'est la fraternité la sororité avec les
êtres humains d'où qu'ils viennent
les valeurs républicaines voilà les
repérer les valeurs républicaines qui
nous anime et elle devrait tous nous
anime et merci la parole est maintenant
notre collègue christian klinger pour le
groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à madame pompili ministre de
la transition écologique
madame la ministre vous avez indiqué sur
un plateau de télévision que les
français pourraient connaître des
coupures électriques
cet hiver madame la ministre et
annoncent jette un froid
cette situation arrive alors que les
deux réacteurs de fessenheim ont été
fermées en 2020 et la fermeture de
fessenheim était une décision politique
et idéologique
alors que la centrale était sur rentable
et qu'elle faisait vivre plus de 2000
foyers fermer fessenheim c'est perdre 1
gigabit 1,8 gigawatts et un visuel
gigawatts c'est ce qui nous manque pour
passer le cap de cet hiver nous allons
donc devoir recourir à quatre centrales
à charbon qu'il reste en france pour
compenser le manque belle réussite de
votre politique écologique
nous allons devoir importer de l'énergie
de nos voisins allemands qui utilisent
des centrales à charbon
belle réussite de votre politique
écologique quoi que l'on en pense
grâce au nucléaire on est indépendant et
on peut passer l'hiver sans coupures
électriques
madame la ministre au vu de ces éléments
regrettez vous d'avoir fermer fessenheim
les français pourront-ils passer l'hiver
au chaud
la france pourra-t-elle garantir dans
les années à venir
son indépendance énergétique
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
ministres en charge des transports
monsieur g baril merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur klinger
merci de cette question qui me permet de
revenir à la fois sur la stabilité du
réseau électrique et au delà sur notre
politique énergétique
d'abord pour vous dire et vous le savez
que le sujet de la disponibilité des
centrales et le fait de des travaux de
maintenance qui ont pris du retard des
faits de la crise du comité 19 et qui
sont actuellement en quelque sorte en
cours de rattrapage mais je tiens à vous
rassurer ici madame compile l'occasion
de le dire il n'y aura pas de coupures
d'approvisionnements cet hiver pour les
français il n'est pas question d'un
quelconque black out pour revenir plus
largement sur le chef de la politique
énergétique vous savez que ce
gouvernement s'est engagé dans une dans
la voie de la diversification en
réduisant progressivement la part du
nucléaire en france dans son mix
électrique avec l'horizon d'atteindre
50% en 2035 contre 72%
aujourd'hui nous développons par
ailleurs et massivement une filières du
renouvelable notamment solaire est
heureux éolien avec plus de 7 milliards
d'euros par an qui sont actuellement
investis et puis sur le plan de la
politique énergétique plus globalement
nous soutenons massivement l'émergence
de la filière hydrogène et la france
peut en la matière de venir j'en suis
convaincu un des leaders mondiaux notre
politique est donc globale non seulement
nous maintenons en conditions
opérationnelles autre filière nucléaire
nous diversifions notre mix énergétique
électrique avec les nerfs et aux
innovations et technologies de rupture
je pense que ce sont là les clés d'une
politique énergétique réussi qui offre à
la fois un haut niveau de services
français et qui maintient des prix bas
quand on les compare notamment avec nos
voisins européens
monsieur klinger
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le ministre des
transports électriques
je crois que là la crise du commis de la
crise ducobu ne peut pas tout elle n'est
pas responsable de tous les maux nous
allons avoir des difficultés aussi les
hivers prochain pour les visites de
maintenance vous savez comme moi
gouverner c'est prévoir la crise du coc
vide a commencé au mois de mars nous
sommes fin novembre ce problème vous
auriez pu largement l'anticiper edf vous
a proposé de prolonger sur fessenheim 1
d un des réacteurs de 900 mégawatts pour
passer l'hiver sereinement
vous l'avez refusé idéologiquement c'est
très simple étant donné la situation
dans laquelle nous risquons de nous
trouver cet hiver
et pour pallier toutes ces coupures
électriques je propose à madame la
ministre de la transition écologique
d'offrir à chaque français sous le sapin
une paire de gants abonnés et de grosses
chaussettes pour passer l'hiver au chaud
allez bien
la parole est notre collègue annie le
héros pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
aujourd'hui 25 novembre journée
internationale pour l'élimination de la
violence à l'égard des femmes en 2010
est notre président de la république a
fait de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes la grande cause de son
quinquennat
141 féminicide en 2019 il faut attendre
le projet de loi de finances 2011 21
pour que des propositions de moyens
supplémentaires il soit loué or malgré
les annonces faites lors du grenelle des
violences conjugales
sans moyens les actions identifiées
connu et expérimentés ne peuvent être
mises en place ni porter leurs fruits
sur le long terme
les forces de l'ordre et de secours font
un travail remarquable pour mettre à
l'abri informer et orienter vers un
accompagnement trop souvent sans
solution en aval elles sont de plus en
plus sollicités en 2020 les violences
intrafamiliales explose de 40% la
plateforme 39,19 dédié aux violences
conjugales a reçu trois fois plus
d'appels mise en place et géré depuis
2000 depuis 1992 par la fédération
solidarité femmes
l adl a démontré son efficacité la
mobilisation de cette équipe
l'annoncé par le gouvernement de sa mise
en concurrence déstabilise une
organisation bien rodée entre la
fédération nationale et son réseau
d'associations locales
la communication ne suffit pas après les
constats il faut des actes monsieur le
premier ministre kan seront disponibles
d hébergement accueil digne et non des
mises à l'abri en urgence dans des
hôtels de passage sur les bords de
quatre voies 2000 places sont des au
minimum de lieux dédiés sont nécessaires
comme les associations seront elles
dotées de moyens leur permet leur
permettant un accompagnement dans la
durée et notamment psychologique de sa
victime de traumatismes sévères
à quand les moyens alloués à la justice
pour écarter sans délai les conjoints
violents tarder bracelet anti
rapprochement
à quand une prise en charge adaptée des
enfants victimes collatérales qui
attendent des mois pour calmer leurs
blessures faute de professionnels
spécialisés
à quand une éducation nationale de nos
garçons et de nos filles dès les petites
classes sur l'égalité des sexes à quand
les formations effectif tout au long de
la vie dans nos
entreprises et administrations sur
l'égalité hommes-femmes et des violences
sexistes et sexuelles au travail
ailleurs quand vous répondre la parole
est aux secrétaires d'état ou poids du
produit riche porte parole du
gouvernement
la parole je suis merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice annie le
houérou je vous remercie pour cette
question qui permet de poursuivre sur le
sujet que nous avons commencé à aborder
tout à l'heure et donc je ne reviendrai
pas sur un certain nombre d'autres fois
que j'ai pu évoquer notamment sur la
question de l'hébergement ou j'ai bien
entendu votre expression qu'il faut des
mille places supplémentaires ce sont les
places que nous créons précisément cette
année et l'année prochaine puisque ce
sera deux mille places en plus qui
auront été créés à la fin 2021 je veux
répondre sur deux points qui me semble
très important dans votre intervention
vous avez abordé la question absolument
centrale de l'éducation dans ce combat
oui elle est centrale
c'est par l'éducation que nous
arriverons à faire changer les
mentalités et un certain nombre de
comportements que nous constatons
aujourd'hui moi je veux rendre hommage à
l'action de jean michel blanquer et
marlène schiappa à l'époque qui ont mis
en place les trois séances obligatoires
d'éducation affective et sexuelle qui
ont été mises en place dans l'éducation
nationale
chaque année c'était prévu par une loi
de 2014 ça n'avait pas été rendue
obligatoire est vendu systématique ça a
été mis en place par ce gouvernement le
deuxième point sur lequel vous avez
interroger le gouvernement
c'est sur la question du 39 19 et donc
de la fnsf depuis des années la fnsf
gère ce numéro 39 19 avec un travail
remarquable et moi je veux saluer on ne
fait pas souvent les écoutantes qui sont
au bout du fil et qui permettent de
gérer de traiter ces situations et
d'orienter les femmes
nous avons renforcé le 39 19 en le
rendant accessible 24 heures sur 24 et 7
jours sur 7
il ya une question qui se pose que vous
avez abordé qui est celle de la commande
publique pourquoi pas sans nous par la
commande publique
parce que dès lors que l'état définit
entièrement les modalités de
fonctionnement seront à sa charge le
projet et le finance en totalité la
commande publique s'impose
l'état entend confirmer et renforcer le
39 19 ans lui donnant une place centrale
dans les politiques publiques de lutte
contre les violences conjugales et moi
je veux vraiment insisté sur le fait que
quels que soient les choix qui devront
être refaits évidemment que nous aurons
une attention absolue à ce que les
écoutantes qui accueilleront les femmes
par téléphone qui continuera à être leur
intérieur
triste soit de la même qualité et
formation que celle que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est absolument fondamental
pour les femmes et c'est ce qui sera
poursuivie par ma collègue elisabeth
moreno qui malheureusement ne peux pas
vous répondre ce qu'elle est en
déplacement avec le président de la
république sur ce sujet merci la parole
et à d'autres collègues chez trial pour
le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
comment en est on arrivé là lundi vous
étirez vous avez réuni l'ensemble des
acteurs de la montagne pour échanger sur
les conditions d'un accueil cet hiver
dans nos stations sur la base d'un
travail sérieux et responsable vous avez
annoncé une décision sous 10 jours
lorsque la situation sanitaire serait
plus clair
hier soir nous avons assisté avec
stupeur aux déclarations du président de
la république
cela a été ressenti comme une trahison
comment en est on arrivé là
depuis votre nomination pour plus
d'efficacité de l'action publique vous
n'avez eu de cesse de nous vanter les
vertus de la décentralisation de la
proximité et du rôle des élus locaux
la gestion de cette crise sanitaire n'a
jamais été aussi centraliser les
situations sont pourtant bien différente
d'un massif à l'autre d'un territoire à
l'autre
comment en est on arrivé là nous ne
comprenons plus rien à votre stratégie
de gestion de crise nous déplorons
l'absence d'une méthode coordonnées et
ne savons même plus qui pilote s'il
existe bien des voitures à deux volants
lorsqu'on se sert des deux en même temps
alors c'est l'accident soit monsieur le
premier ministre vous n'étiez pas
informé des déclarations du président de
la république hier soir et cela pose le
problème de la gouvernance à la tête de
l'état soit vous l'étiez et dans ce cas
vous nous avez raconté des
calembredaines ce qui pose un problème
de crédibilité à la tête de l'état
comment en est on arrivé là nous savons
que la situation sanitaire n'est pas
bonne et que la pression sur le monde
hospitalier forte mais nous le voyons
mais nous voyons cas s'est
considérablement améliorée ces derniers
temps et que son évolution nous offre
espoir et perspectives
chaque année accueillir les touristes en
station constitue une prouesse
sanitaires réalisés sans encombre la
fréquentation attendue cette saison est
en baisse de 50%
des personnels médicaux saisonniers sont
d'ores et déjà prévues dès le 15
décembre une politique de tests massive
a été prévu par la région et par les
départements nous pourrions être très en
toute sécurité
monsieur le premier ministre pouvez vous
nous confirmer que la concertation entre
le gouvernement et les acteurs de la
montagne est toujours d'actualité et que
la décision sera finalement basée sur
des éléments objectifs plutôt que sur
des arbres des appréciations à
l'emporte-pièce jour merci pour vous
répondre
la parole est au qatar et à charge du
tourisme
jean-baptiste lemoyne monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs sénatrice monsieur le sénateur
vial la déception on à mesure tous je la
mesure tout particulièrement la colère
parfois oui il y à une heure j'étais
d'ailleurs en réunion avec le président
des domaines skiables de l'aisne msm de
l'anem des écoles de ski pour travailler
à la suite j'ai pu mesurer parce que ce
travail
ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'on conduit
que le monde de la montagne ce sont des
acteurs qui sont sérieux qui sont
responsables ils veulent juste
travailler et donc ils ne sont pas en
cause
ce qui est en cause c'est une situation
sanitaire qui même si elle s'améliore
demeure très tendue
ce qui est en cause c'est aussi
l'évolution des intentions des états
voisins
je pense à l'italie je pense à
l'allemagne et ses intentions ont été
manifestées postérieurement à la réunion
qu'a tenu le premier ministre le premier
ministre a réuni les acteurs lundi il a
souhaité que le travail puisse se
poursuivre le travail va se poursuivre
et le président l'a souhaité aussi
naturellement dans des directions un peu
complémentaire c'est à dire tu te voir
quelles sont les activités qui
pourraient être autorisées la raquette
est-ce que les jardins d'enfants en
plein air tout ça ça reste à travailler
à discuter
quel est le soutien économique qui doit
être justement renforcée pour aider les
acteurs pour aider les acteurs à faire
face à cette situation particulièrement
complexe parce qu'on le sait noël c'est
à peu près 20% ou 25% de la saison mais
ce qu'on veut justement c'est préserver
le coeur de la saison est d'ailleurs
book
hector l'on dit rien ne serait pire que
d'ouvrir puis de devoir fermer à cause
d'une mauvaise évolution et donc nous
allons travailler continuer à travailler
d'arrache-pied dans les mesures je pense
qu'il faut regarder le président était
très ouvert peut être aussi à plus de
classe de neige le moment venu parce
qu'on a besoin aussi et bien de
réamorcer la pompe de ce point de vue là
à faire que les jeunes redécouvrent à la
montagne je peux vous dire qu en tous
les cas nous allons travailler et être
aux côtés des acteurs de la montagne
monsieur rial monsieur monsieur le
ministre ce n'est pas sérieux
l'allemagne et l'italie ne sont pas les
concurrents de nos stations c'est
l'autriche c'est la suisse qui l ont
pris la décision d'ouvrir et la
clientèle française sera au rendez-vous
à l'étranger on devra gérer ensuite le
retour de ces français dans des stations
sanitaires notamment en suisse pire que
celle qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
merci la parole
et notre collègue lana tetuanui
s'allumer collecte et accepte d'être
dans les tribunes ici et qui participent
à nos questions vers la parole ma chère
collègue pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues et yoram monsieur le premier
ministre la crise sanitaire n'épargne
pas les outre-mer au général et je
crains fort que nous soyons les oubliés
de la république à laver ou le
gouvernement polynésien déposera son
projet de budget 2021 à l'assemblée de
polynésie française et à la lecture du
plf 2021 et du plan de relance
je ne retrouve pas la traduction des
engagements de l'état convenir l'égard
de ma collectivité en premier lieu
l'absence des 12 millions d'euros se
rapportant à la convention est un pays
relative à la santé à la solidarité
garantie d'un niveau d'accès aux soins
pour l'ensemble des citoyens français du
pacifique est un impératif
en second lieu seront prêts garantis par
l'état pour l'exercice 2010 21 est
attendu dans le cadre des contrats de
développement et de transformation 2021
2003 il n'y a aucune visibilité sur le
montant réservé à la polynésie française
notre tourisme qui est et qui reste le
premier moteur de notre économie reste
le vecteur pourvoyeur d'emplois est en
berne depuis vos annonces du 30 octobre
dernier
alors monsieur le premier ministre
quelles mesures immédiates pouvez-vous
envisager pour maintenir nos emplois
liés au tourisme l'est pas tiendra-t-il
ses engagements vis-à-vis de mac
collectivités ou devons-nous en conclut
que nos statuts spécifiques d'autonomie
constitue une limite et non le gage
d'une confiance réciproque entre l'état
et ces collectivités d'outre-mer je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole les
communistes d outre-mer monsieur lecornu
vous avez la parole
si monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs même la
sénatrice devait raison de rappeler la
violence avec laquelle elle oscille
l'épidémie sévit dans les différents
territoires d'outre-mer et
singulièrement dans votre territoire
peut-être aussi saluer ici publiquement
au nom du gouvernement la manière dont
les choses se passent avec le président
edouard fritch président du pays de la
polynésie française sur lequel la
qualité de la collaboration la maturité
des décisions qui sont prises nous
permettre de faire au mieux dans un
territoire grand comme l'europe et sur
lequel évidemment les décisions sont
parfois difficiles à prendre sur le
terrain financier la solidarité
nationale a largement été appelé
d'ailleurs c'est grâce à l'ensemble des
parlementaires ici qu'ils ont voté alors
évidemment parfois sur des sur des
chants sur lequel d'ailleurs l'état
n'est plus compétent mais sur lequel le
pays il est aujourd'hui le fonds de
solidarité
par exemple pour les entreprises depuis
mars une somme un chiffre 63 millions
d'euros les pge 435 millions d'euros y
compris pour le transport aérien
également le prêt au pays un premier
prêt au pays de 140 millions d'euros
plus des prêts spécifiques alors on va
continuer pour répondre très précisément
à votre question à répondre à cet effort
de solidarité or si vous ne le savez pas
déjà le présent fritsch évidemment lui
le sait sur évidemment un nouveau prêt
potentiel pour le pays vous
m'interpeller je vous réponds il faut
évaluer le besoin en trésorerie précis
réel pour le pays de la polynésie
française pour pouvoir le documenter
évidemment sur la convention santé
je me suis engagé le premier ministre
s'est engagé devant vous d'ailleurs et
devant une délégation polynésienne
parce que cette convention santé soit
efficace et effective pour 2020 c'est le
cas pour 2021
ça sera le cas également si vous ne
retrouvez pas dans le plf c'est tout
simplement parce que sont des sommes qui
sont dans programme 123 qui sera amené à
la discussion ici dans maintenant
quelques jours au sénat dans le cadre du
projet de finances pour l'année
prochaine donc cette solidarité
on y répondra en a déjà commencé à faire
depuis le mois de mars
il n'y aucune raison d'en douter madame
la sénatrice en tout cas le président
fritsch le sait après puisque vous
m'interrogez sur la question des
compétences de l'autonomie versus la
solidarité il ya une vraie question sur
les questions de crise et d'urgence
et ça c'est peut-être une réflexion dans
le sénat peut s'emparer y compris en
portant la question de la fiscalité
puisque bien évidemment lorsqu'on traite
de ces questions notamment pour
l'accompagnement des entreprises ça
renvoie la question fiscale en tout cas
on est prêt à répondre à vos attentes
ce sujet adoptez toile et vous avez
quelques secondes
chers collègues oui merci monsieur le
ministre mais excusez moi
quelquefois on s'y perd un peu entre les
paroles et les actes
il y avait quand même une différence
merci qui la parole est à notre collègue
laurent burgoa pour le groupe les red
bull league
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre la cohésion des territoires des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
madame le ministre jusqu'ici malgré les
pétitions de principe réitéré comme pour
conjurer la réalité vécue sur le terrain
par les élus locaux
la crise du coc vide aura été celle du
triomphe du jacobinisme
c'est à paris que tout se décide un
point c'est tout cette crise totalement
verticale du pouvoir a conduit un grand
journal allemand a renommé la france lab
surkis thann et hier le rythme s'est
même accélérée le président de la
république en hausse que 30 personnes
pourront participer aux offices
religieux et pas plus tard que ce matin
nous apprenons que vous revenez déjà sur
cette annonce
une telle absurdité ne se serait pas
produite si vous aviez laissé les
autorités locales maires et préfets
adapter les mesures en fonction de leur
territoire la période peu glorieuse où
il y avait pénurie de masques a pourtant
montré que la proximité trouver des
solutions là où l'hyper concentration
était impuissante pour être efficace la
lutte contre la pandémie aurait dû et
doit être menée en lien étroit avec les
maires les premiers ministres qui se
sont succédé à n'ont fait des éléments
de discours mais jamais les moyens n'ont
été donnée aux couples préfet maire pour
fonctionner réellement hier le président
de la république comme si la crise ne
faisait que commencer l'a redit le
couple préfet maire c'est la solution
mais en réalité il n'y a jamais eu
co construction et les mères sont
souvent considérés comme des exécutants
sa marge de manoeuvre une étude récente
réalisée en partenariat avec la mfr
d'ailleurs montré qu'une majorité de
maires de me redresser un constat
négatif de leurs relations avec l'état
comme à madame la ministre vous qui êtes
en charge des relations avec les
collectivités locales
expliquez vous ces résultats comment
comptez-vous faire en sorte que les
maires soient pleinement associées aux
décisions qui concernent leur territoire
qui connaissent mieux que personne
je vous remercie pour vos répondre la
parole le terminus de la cohésion des
territoires des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur laurent burgoa
d'abord commençons par le début
nous sommes en pleine crise sanitaire
bien évidemment et vous savez que c'est
l'état qui est responsable et qui gère
la crise sanitaire sur le territoire
premier point et même monsieur baroin
dans ses déclarations ne cesse de le
répéter
deuxième point deuxième point
vous n'avez pas les mêmes sources que
moi sur les sondages ce que j'ai lu un
excellent petit papier publié par
l'association des maires de france qui
aurait dû tenir son congrès aujourd'hui
mais qui évidemment ne veut pas le tenir
et qui a fait un sondage d'opinion qui a
été menée par le cevipof et on interroge
les maires et on leur demande est ce que
vous êtes content de votre relation
maire préfet 68%
je le dis de mémoire mais je ne crois
pas me tromper 68% des maires sont
satisfaits de leur relation avec leurs
préfets j'ajoute bien sûr les
sous-préfets car il faut prendre le
corps préfectoral dans son ensemble
troisièmement c'est le premier ministre
qui a mis en avant le couple préfets
maires et bien entendu c'est normal
puisque c'est l'efficacité des
politiques publiques qui sont menées sur
les territoires ne marche pas ce sens là
ans des préfet et des élus locaux c'est
absolument indispensable dans beaucoup
de public de politiques publiques que
nous menons et a fortiori pour la crise
sanitaire
pas plus tard qu'hier et tous les jours
je suis en relation avec les préfets et
avec les élus locaux
j'ai mené je mène des concertations tous
les jours avec toutes les strates de
collectivités territoriales et nous
avons discuté hier encore de des tests
qui sont les tests antigénique qui sont
actuellement développés sur les
territoires et comment ça se passe et
ben d'éclat mais les maires et les
préfets
il n'y a pas d'autre solution donc c'est
tout à fait faux monsieur le sénateur ce
que vous dites
la concertation existe et l'action sur
les territoires existent merci
la parole qu'à de notre collègue rémi
gardon pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes rqge merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au premier ministre
le président des restos du coeur patrice
blanc s'est dit bouleversé par l'image
des jeunes arrivant aux restos du coeur
avec la retenue le rite
il apporte à manger et ils n'ont pas de
quoi manger pour eux monsieur le premier
ministre je tenais à vous parler d'un
sujet qui me tient à coeur qui nous
tient à coeur qui engagent notre pays et
son avenir
la situation de notre jeunesse la
situation due à la copie 19 a encore
dégradé les conditions de vie des jeunes
le chômage des actifs de moins de 25 ans
a bondi
il pourrait dépasser les 30% à la fin de
l'année un jeune de moins de 25 ans sur
cinq est en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
les épiceries sociales sont débordés les
soins médicaux sont sont un luxe pour
nombre d'entre eux cette génération qui
consent à tous les sacrifices est en
train de souffrir terriblement et ne
connaîtra en retour qu'un marché de
l'emploi très difficile ou inaccessibles
pourtant ils bénéficient le moins de
deux mesures de solidarité ils sont
exclus les principaux dispositifs de
lutte contre la pauvreté comme le revenu
de solidarité active
la france tournait le dos à la sa
jeunesse je vous pose la question
votre plan jeunesse modeste compilation
de vieilles recettes n'apporte que peu
de réponses à cette urgence
est ce la bonne démarche l'horizon
proposé à la jeunesse ne peut pas se
résumer à l'emploi
il est temps de repenser les politiques
publiques de jeunesse dans une approche
globale et transversale est temps de
considérer que les jeunes comme une
opportunité comme le socle de notre
avenir et non comme seulement des
victimes ou une menace
face à la violence de la situation
actuelle qui frappe encore plus durement
les jeunes
comment allez-vous répondre à l'urgence
et redonner un avenir à notre jeunesse
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et d'innovation madame frédéric vidal
merci monsieur le président mesdames
destinatrice messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur cardon la précarité
de la jeunesse c'est une réalité je
crois que la nier ou ou la sous-estimer
serait une erreur et je crois que s'y
résoudre ce serait une erreur plus grave
encore c'est pourquoi le gouvernement a
mobilisé depuis le premier confinement
et c'est à nouveau le cas lors de ce
deviennent deuxième confinement de très
nombreux leviers
je peux vous parler de ce qui s'est
passé pour les étudiants par exemple
pendant le premier confinement c'est
plus de 19 millions d'euros qui sont
venus en aide aux étudiants les plus
précaires avec des aides numérique d
aide alimentaire d aide sanitaire aussi
et notamment pour pour les jeunes femmes
un accompagnement remarquable qui a été
menée par les crous et par les
établissements et puis toutes les
mesures que nous avons mises en place
notamment l'accompagnement de 200 euros
pour tous ceux qui avaient perdu leur
job étudiant ou encore la prolongation
des bourses sur critères sociaux pour
ceux dont les examens avaient été
retardés et puis il ya ce deuxième
confinement et ce plan inédit annoncée
par le premier ministre un jeune une
solution nous y avons travaillé en
interministériel
c'est la possibilité pour les
entreprises de maintenir l'apprentissage
avec finalement des résultats pour
l'apprentissage en 2020 qui sont
meilleur encore que ceux de 2019 qui
avaient déjà été une année
exceptionnelle c'est aussi l'aide à
l'embauché des jeunes par les
entreprises
un soutien pour les premiers contrats et
les premiers contrats de travail s'est
encore l'aide aux étudiants avec d'ici
quelques jours
versement de 150 euros pour tous les
étudiants boursiers pour tous les jeunes
bénéficiaires des apl c'est le ticket ru
à 1 euro avec là encore une mobilisation
exceptionnelle des crous qui prennent
les commandes des jeunes qui font sens
qu'ils aient des repas chauds équilibré
qu'il puisse les faire réchauffer qu'il
puisse prendre plusieurs repas pour ne
pas avoir à se déplacer plusieurs fois
par jour alors oui la précarité est une
réalité c'est une réalité depuis
longtemps et nous y travaillons et nous
proposons des solutions globales en lien
avec toutes les associations garderont
un jeu une solution ne répond pas à
l'urgence et reste largement sous
dimensionné et vous aurez la chance de
vous rattraper
le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains vous donne rendez vous dans
quelques semaines pour parler d'une
proposition de loi relative au droit
nouveau dès 18 ans avec une perspective
universelle est plus structurel avec le
projet de loi des aides individuelles
aliments si passion je vous remercie
la parole est à d'autres collègues
stéphane pieds noirs pour le groupe
l'est républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre alors que
nous sommes encore au coeur de la
deuxième vague de lakovic 19
c'est une véritable lame de fond aux
effets potentiels assez sévère qui est
en train de se former
je veux parler de la santé des français
et en particulier des jeunes ainsi après
une dernière année de lycée largement
tronqué les nouveaux étudiants abordent
ce virage important de l'entrée dans les
études post bac dans des conditions
extrêmement dégradée
l'absence de cours en présentiel
probablement encore pour deux mois
encore implique une durée d'exposition
aux écrans extrêmement élevés parfois
plus de dix heures par jour et une
inactivité physique qui interroge alors
même que l'on cesse publie un avis qui
interroge qui alertent les pouvoirs
publics sur les risques sanitaires
inhérents à ce type de comportement
mauvaises habitudes hellemmes
alimentaire obésité anxiété troubles du
sommeil sont des conséquences qui sont
bien identifiés mais aujourd'hui un
certain nombre d'étudiants avoue être en
fragilité psychologique
lié à une sévère rupture sociale
ils ont quitté depuis peu leur cocon
familial protecteur et ils n'ont pas
encore eu le temps de reconstruire de
construire leur réseau d'amis dans leur
nouvel environnement
les services de santé des universités
alerte d'ailleurs et font un constat en
cette période propice au décrochage
entre la toussaint et noël les appels à
l'aide sont fréquents sont nombreux et
ne rencontrent malheureusement pas
l'accompagnement psychologique de
proximité nécessaires sur le terrain
le premier ministre a certes récemment
annoncé le déploiement de 1600 emplois
étudiants dans les cités universitaires
mais cela ne concerne justement que les
résidents de ces cités universitaires
c'est-à-dire 7% seulement des étudiants
madame la ministre que pauvre que
prévoyez vous de faire pour les 93
autres pourcents pour vous répondre la
parole de la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche l'innovation
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur pieds noirs là
aussi vous soulever une question qui est
une vraie importance y compris pour
l'avenir de notre pays parce que je
crois que des jeunes qui vivent cette
crise des jeunes qui sont soumis à ces
aléas psychologique comme l'ensemble de
la population mais parfois avec des
effets plus graves sur parce qu'ils sont
en train de se construire
et bien c'est aussi un risque pour notre
avenir pour la confiance qu'ils vont
pouvoir exprimer dans leur pays et dans
la société en général qui doit être en
mesure de les accompagner
c'est pourquoi elle a aussi plusieurs
dispositifs ont été mis en place vous
avez rappelé les 1600 emplois étudiants
référents dans les cités universitaires
600 d'entre eux sont déjà au travail 400
sont en cours de recrutement
ce qui signifie que en trois semaines
nous aurons recruté les 1600 c'est aussi
30 mille tuteur qui ont été recrutés par
les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur pour accompagner les jeunes
qui justement ont pu connaître une phase
terminale compliquée et qui ont connu un
début dans l'enseignement supérieur tout
aussi compliqué la difficulté en réalité
c'est qu'il faut convaincre les jeunes
que la prévention est quelque chose
d'important pour eux et ils se sentent
jeunes et se sentent en bonne santé et
parfois ils ont un peu de mal à louer
c'est pour ça il ya aussi ce travail de
fond que nous menons avec le ministère
des solidarités de la santé depuis plus
de trois ans sur la question de la
prévention la prévention sur tous les
sujets la prévention aussi sur la
question de la santé mentale
il faut que les jeunes osent dire qu'ils
ne vont pas bien et ne le disent jamais
mieux qu'à d'autres jeunes c'est
pourquoi nous avons mis en place les
services sanitaires qui sont des équipes
pluridisciplinaires entre des étudiants
en santé qui peuvent aller à la
rencontre de ces jeunes c'est pourquoi
évidemment les services de santé
universitaire travail c'est pourquoi
plus de 36 maisons santé ont été
ouvertes au sein des universités pour
que les jeunes et des relais envers
d'autres jeunes qui vont pouvoir les
diriger vers des professionnels de santé
et là encore je voudrais saluer le
travail mené par les ss eu par les
associations par les bénévoles par tous
ceux qui nous permettent de donner un
avenir à notre jeunesse monsieur
pieds-noirs quelques secondes la
ministre partageons le constat sur l'
isolement et la fragilité des étudiants
j'entends la facilité de s'ouvrir à
d'autres des jeunes du même âge
néanmoins notre système de
l'enseignement supérieur souffre d'un
manque de moyens humains
on compte par exemple un psychologue
pour trente mille étudiants en france
c'est un ratio qui est de 1 pour capter
dans d'autres pays c'est peut-être aussi
une question une moment de s'interroger
sur ce type de relation en france merci
merci de donner la parole à madame
laurence garnier pour le groupe l'est
républicain je salue sa première prise
de parole comme sénateur de loire
atlantique
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
il y à une zone de non droit qui s'est
installé il ya plusieurs semaines sur le
site du carnet en loire atlantique où
des dizaines de à dist occupent
illégalement la zone ils ont détérioré
la route départementale ils ont
construit des barricades pour contester
un projet de développement du grand port
maritime de nantes saint nazaire
ce projet c'est l'installation
d'entreprises écotechnologiques sur 110
hectares avec près de
100 hectares qui sont préservés dans le
cadre de la compensation écologique
alors vous le voyez monsieur le premier
ministre sur ce dossier
les enjeux sont clairs c'est à la fois
le développement économique du pays et
la restauration de l'autorité de l'état
en loire atlantique malheureusement nous
connaissons bien les adh puisque en 2018
emmanuel macron avait déjà donné raison
aux à dist et aux ultra violent en
renonçant aux projets de notre dame des
landes pourtant soutenu par de nombreux
élus locaux validée par un référendum
local et par 200 décisions de justice
aujourd'hui monsieur le premier ministre
les élus du territoire sont démunis ils
ont demandé à vos services si des
poursuites avaient été engagées contre
les manifestations non déclarées de ces
derniers mois il leur a été répondu que
les services de l'état étaient seuls
juges d'engager ou non des poursuites
monsieur le premier ministre l'état ne
doit plus jamais cédé devant
l'illégalité et la violence ma question
est donc clair quand allez-vous évacuer
la zad du carnet pour vous pour vous
répondre
la parole est à jean baptiste jebbari
ministre délégué des transports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice garnier vous interroger le
gouvernement sur l'aménagement du site
de carnets qui fait partie des emprises
du grand port maritime de nantes saint
nazaire
le projet a été instruit selon la
procédure d'autorisation unique loi sur
l'eau et a fait l'objet vous le savez un
arrêté préfectoral d'autorisation
environnementale s'est arrêté a par
ailleurs été purgés de tout recours
ce projet vous l'avez rappelé répond à
des raisons impératives d'intérêt public
au travers notamment du développement
des énergies marines renouvelables et à
comité de suivi a été mise en place pour
suivre l'évolution des travaux en
décembre 2007 le collectif stop carnet
vous l'avez rappelé menu une
contestation de ce projet d'aménagement
et a déjà organisé plusieurs
manifestations qui ont réuni entre 20 et
200 personnes à ce jour une trentaine de
pays
sun reste sur le site de carnets un
moratoire d'une année a été annoncé le 4
novembre dernier par le grand port
maritime afin de compléter les études
déjà réalisées sans levé l'occupation du
site
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs le
bailleur juste eu raison a déposé
plainte pour violation de domicile le
gouvernement appelle au respect du
moratoire de manière à ce que les freins
et les doutes sur le projet soit levé et
qu'il puisse se dérouler de façon
cohérente dans le respect de l'ordre
public voilà mais gardez vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le ministre je dois dire
que je suis assez surprise que ce soit
vous en tant que ministre délégué aux
transports qui répondiez sur ce dossier
j'aurais préféré que le premier ministre
qui a réaffirmé avec force tout à
l'heure l'autorité de l'état sur le camp
de migrants évacués à paris fasse la
même chose sur ce dossier devant les
sénateurs
l'indignation à géométrie variable c'est
trop facile
monsieur le premier ministre madame et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues merci prochaines questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
uno très bien le mercredi 9 décembre à
15h en raison du budget je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h30 pour l'examen de la proposition de
résolution d'applications l'article 34-1
de la constitution portant sur la
nécessité de reconnaître la république
du haut karabakh
la séance est suspendue voilà pour cette
séance de questions d'actualité que vous
avez pu suivre en intégralité en direct
sur public sénat une question une séance
de questions lors de laquelle il y a eu
beaucoup de questions autour de la
qu'ovide sous l'angle économique sous
l'angle de l'impact sur la jeunesse ou
encore la scolarité mais peu peu de
précisions supplémentaires car
effectivement on attend et bien
notamment la conférence de presse demain
de jean castex et tout de suite on va
aller salle des conférences car
alexandre poussard est avec le président
du groupe l'est républicain bruno
retailleau
mais oui on attend des précisions sur ce
confinement allégé qui a été dessiné
dans les grands traits par emmanuel
macron alors bruno retailleau les
commerces vont réouvrir les salles de
spectacles également dans un deuxième
temps on a un calendrier on a un câble
c'est plutôt positif
bien sûr qu'on est un cap condé des
calendriers il reste quand même un
certain nombre d' absurdité on pense par
exemple au fameux à l'as josh de 30
personnes seulement que ce soit dans une
petite chapelle où une grande cathédrale
je dis d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises
que une voiture de tgv c'est 60
personnes à peu près tranquille on met
dans 20 grandes cathédrales la moitié
d'une rame de tgv
il reste aussi quand même un souci avec
les restaurateurs je pense qu'il faut
travailler le 20 janvier ce n'est pas
une fatalité
vous prenez là encore une fois le tgv
vous avez à côté de vous des gens qui
mangent vote leur sandwich par exemple
donc il faut rester cohérent en tout cas
il ya des progrès et moi qui me suis
battu pour l'ouverture des commerces de
proximité je me félicite qu'ils puissent
ouvrir bientôt et ça c'est important
pour le week-end prochain
alors effectivement et encore de
l'inquiétude pour certains secteurs qui
vont rester fermés notamment
la restauration mais le ministre de
l'économie ce matin dit qu'il faut
rester optimiste avoir l'esprit de
résistance et d'ailleurs il dénonce
l'esprit de défaite je cite de certains
responsables politiques et ils vous cite
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez sans
doute que j'ai d'une titiller un petit
peu puisque je passais sur cette radio
france inter du tout plutôt que lui non
ce que j'ai dis moi ce que je dis depuis
le mois de mars
c'est que malheureusement on le verra
dans quelques mois mais on le voit déjà
la france a de mauvais résultats en
termes de mortalité alors que la france
est au premier rang en termes de
dépenses publiques
il ya quelque chose qui ne colle pas
quand emmanuel macron dit j'ai protégé
les français
il l'est pas n'a pas bien protégé est ce
que je dis moi c'est que les mails
macron hier nous a promis en réalité en
terme de stratégie ce que depuis neuf
mois il n'a pas réussi à faire c'est à
dire à contenir l'épidémie en dépistant
en traçant réellement et j'ai fait des
propositions et parle isolement des cas
contactez puisqu'il vaut beaucoup mieux
isoler les malades que les bien portants
et justement il y aura normalement en
isolement contrat c'est ce qu'a annoncé
le président la république ans il a
l'air plutôt favorable mais c'est le
parlement qui va définir cet isolement
contre un pour les malades de lakovic 19
vous êtes favorable à bruno retailleau
et si oui à quelle formule de satie
seulement moi je vais vous dire je
réclame
cet isolement depuis des mois et des
mois dans mon département c'est souvent
un exemple que je prends il ya eu trois
isolement un sdf de travailleurs
étrangers simplement avant de se
demander s'il isolement devait être
obligatoire ou contraints ou simplement
accompagnée il faut déjà le rendre
possible
c'est ça que je demande ensuite qu'il y
ait un débat pas de problème on pourrait
résonner sur par exemple d isolement
qu'ils soient contrôlés un petit peu
comme les arrêts de travail
mais d'abord faisons en sorte que dans
chaque département il ya des coupes des
capacités notamment thème d'hôtellerie
pour recueillir des malades qu'ils
n'aillent pas ensuite contaminer
notamment leurs familles leurs foyers
ouais merci beaucoup à bruno retailleau
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci merci beaucoup alexandre pour
cette première réaction à l'issue de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et vous l'avez entendu un
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
et leur ici au sénat reste extrêmement
critique un concernant est bien là j
si on de la crise sanitaire par le
gouvernement et cela malgré bien le
calendrier qui a été hier développé par
emmanuel macron et on va continuer bien
les réactions sur ce même sujet car
alexandre vous êtes avec brigitte
bourguignon la ministre déléguée auprès
du ministre des solidarités et de la
santé elle est chargée de l'autonomie
elle va aussi vous parler bien sûr de et
bien du confinement et de cet allègement
du confinement
mais oui on va parler de la partie
sanitaire de ceux des confinement
bonjour brigitte bourguignon alors
emmanuel macron a évoqué la stratégie de
vaccination avec un début de la
vaccination en france entre la mi
décembre et le mois de janvier est ce
qu'on va pas un peu vite et c'est ce
qu'on va apporter toutes les garanties
aux français sur ce vaccin
je pense que la france avance prudemment
salué même reproché or nous prenons
effectivement toute la prudence
nécessaire quant au déploiement de ce
vaccin même si maintenant nous savons
que nous serons prêts prochainement pour
ce déploiement est avec une priorisation
aussi dans les publics
évidemment au départ parce que il faut
d'abord cibler les personnes les plus
vulnérables vous l'avez vu les soignants
et bien sûr les personnes âgées en
feront partie
évidemment et puis il va y avoir le défi
de faire accepter cette vaccination aux
français dont beaucoup sont sceptiques
face au vaccin
le président l'a dit hier il n'y aura
pas de vaccination obligatoire mais ce
que cette solution de la vaccination
obligatoire ce n'est pas le seul moyen
d'avoir une immunité collective assez
rapidement c'est une façon oui bien sûr
de rassurer aussi parce que nous voulons
tous et c'est le notre bien commun que
nous n'ayons plus de troisième vague ni
de confinement parce que nous luttons
tous en tout cas et c'est pour ça que
les propos du président ont été pleins
d'humilité et aussi de sécurité parce
que nous allons faire cela en est en
phase où vous l'avez entendu celle qui
commence le 28 novembre puis celle qui
commence le 15 décembre puis celle qui
viendra en janvier tout ça est
progressif pour évaluer la situation
sanitaire lorsqu'il faudra donc je crois
que évidemment cette vaccination va
arriver à point nommé pour permettre de
sortir vraiment définitivement de la
crise peut-être
et puis il y aura un collectif citoyen
qui va travailler sur cette vaccination
est en transe pour restaurer la
confiance
absolument je pense que dans 1
imad défiance vous l'avez vu très
souvent je pense qu'il est utile aussi
que nous nous appuyons sur un conseil de
scientifiques mais aussi de citoyens
pour qu'il y ait un maximum de
transparence
alors le président a évoqué également un
isolement contraint des malades de
lakovic 19
c'est le parlement qui va définir la
forme de cet isolement contre un mais
sur quelle piste et bien on peut
travailler qu est ce qu on pourrait
imaginer alors moi pour l'instant je
n'ai pas les pistes parce que vous le
savez tous sera plus précis dans la
conférence de presse demain qui sera
tenu par le premier ministre pour
l'instant nous avons le cadre général et
ensuite je serai en mesure bien sûr de
vous en parler plus plus aisément
mais en tout cas une chose est sûre
c'est que toute cette prudence qui
continuera d'être au rendez-vous va être
le fil conducteur de toutes les actions
et toutes les prises de décisions qui
seront prises ensuite est ce qu'on
pourrait aller vers un système à la
coréenne où les personnes sont isolées
dans des hôtels ça a été proposée vous
le savez vous rappelez dans la première
vague ça n'a pas eu un franc succès les
gens sont très très sensible à la
question des libertés individuelles dans
notre pays donc tout ça doit être
concertée bien sûr les parlementaires
auront leur rôle à jouer dans cette
définition du cadre nécessaire s'étant
trouvé trouvé une chance tu essais
libres il faut trouver le juste
équilibre
ça a été pareil sur les personnes âgées
et sur leur isolement merci beaucoup aux
brigitte bourguignon d'avoir répondu à
mes questions après cette séance de
questions d'actualité
merci merci beaucoup alexandrins voilà
pour ces différentes réactions notamment
et bien sûr la pandémie de l'aco vides
et alors que demain on attend
effectivement et bien la conférence de
presse du premier ministre jean castex
autre thématique très importante lors de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
la question des forces de l'ordre après
l'adoption de la loi sécurité globale à
l'assemblée nationale et notamment
l'article 24 articles polémiques qui
empêche la diffusion d'image des forces
de l'ordre dans une intention
malveillante il ya eu plusieurs
questions à ce sujet et notamment le
point d'orgue est bien ça a été les
changes entre guillaume gontard le
président du groupe écologiste
ici au sénat et c'est jean castex le
premier ministre qui a répondu il est
venu assurer les forces de l'ordre de
son soutien total
il a dit également que toutes les
procédures seraient suivis
cernon et bien les images choquantes de
du démantèlement de camps migrants place
de la république lundi et quant à
l'article 24 écouterez sa réponse
article 24 danger les 10 hier à
l'assemblée je ne doute pas que le sénat
l'examinera dans un souci de le
clarifier n'a pas d'autre but
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
de protéger les forces de sécurité s'en
porter en quoi que ce soit atteinte à la
liberté
sacré de la presse et la liberté
d'expression
lisez lisez ce texte est pas tous les
commentaires erronés qui en sont faits
plus que jamais plus que jamais la
liberté la sécurité sont des valeurs au
coeur de la république que ce
gouvernement défendra et défendra
toujours
voilà pour la réponse tout à l'heure du
premier ministre et tout de suite on va
salle des conférences
car guillaume gontard un sénateur
écologiste et président de ce groupe qui
interpellait le premier ministre tout à
l'heure est au micro d'alexandre pour
intervenir notamment et bien sûr les
événements qui ont eu lieu lundi soir
place de la république
et oui avec guillaume gontard pour
revenir sur l'un des moments forts de
cette séance de questions d'actualité
votre échange du bon temps avec le
premier ministre jean castex pour
revenir sur l'évacuation de migrants
place de la république
lundi soir une évacuation musclée et le
premier ministre l'a justifiée et
finalement c'était une et bien une
occupation illégale de la place de la
république
c'est vrai que le fait à la fois de
justifier ce qui ce qui a pu se passer
place place de la république et puis et
puis ces mots me dire la république
c'est la sécurité
non la république c'est la liberté c'est
l'égalité c'est la fraternité et c'est
surtout un état de droit et c'est la
responsabilité du premier ministre du
gouvernement de faire en sorte que cette
droite a de droit fonctionne et là on
est sur une dérive totalement
sécuritaire
le fait qu'on ne se pose pas les
questions sur ce qui s'est passé même en
matière symbolique place de la
république
le tout sera complètement avant et
portant justement sur ces violences de
certains policiers le
gouvernement a quand même réagi en
diligentant une enquête de l'inspection
générale de la police nationale en
condamnant médiatiquement ces violences
le gouvernement et à la victoire sur ce
mais encore une fois je les dis dans
cette danse est question c'est pas c'est
pas de pointer du doigt le travail des
policiers et la question des policiers
il peut y avoir comme dans toute
corporation des problématiques la vraie
responsabilité elle et du gouvernement
les du ministre de l'intérieur et de ces
messages qui sont envoyées et de cette
dérive sécuritaire de cette chaîne de
commandement du du préfet l'allemand
dont on se demande comment il peut être
encore en fonction avec les bavures qui
se succèdent continuellement comment on
peut imaginer qu'à préfet puisse encore
être en fonction aujourd'hui avec ce qui
s'est passé lundi dire même vu de
l'extérieur vu de l'ensemble des autres
pays
c'est inimaginable mais justement ce que
vous appelez la dérive sécuritaire de la
part du gouvernement est ce que ça ne
répond pas à une montée de la violence
dans notre pays et notamment et bien
dans un contexte terroristes mais de
quoi de quoi on parle
kane avec des magnifiques est ce que
c'était c'était une manifestation
peut-être pour visibiliser un problème
parce que cette question des migrants
ces évacuations qui se font c'est sûr
que d'habitude ace combat des villes est
cependant dans les banlieues où on les
voit pas c'était justement pour montrer
pourquoi que les images avaient leur
importance et je rappelle qu'on a un
article 24 qui veut nous supprimer
justement cet accès cet accès cet accès
à l'image et donc c'était important
parce que ce qu'on a vu place de la
république
ça se passe quasi tous les jours partout
en france et alors justement on va en
parler de cet article 24 de la
proposition proposition de loi pardon
sécurité globale une un article qui
visait bien à punir la diffusion
malveillantes d'image de policiers en
intervention
cet article et ce texte va donc arriver
au sénat il a été adopté à l'assemblée
est-ce que vous voterez en l'état cet
article 24 mais bien sûr que non ça veut
dire que vous avez coupe
comment vous allez lire et écrire mais
je pense que surtout on va le rejeter en
bloc le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoires je laissais c'est toute la
philosophie de ce texte
on est sur une dérive totalement
sécuritaire et pays à cet article cet
article 24 mai quand on est en train de
réfléchir au fonctionnement des drones
sur la surveillance dans quelle société
on veut nous faire vivre et donc c'est
toute cette philosophie philosophie là
qu'il faut qu'il faut rejeter et qui en
total désaccord avec nos valeurs
républicaines
on sent qu'il ya un problème de
philosophie entre vous et le
gouvernement d'un côté jean castex qui
dit la république c'est d'abord protéger
les français et vous qui dites la
république c'est la liberté la
fraternité
je pense que c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est ce qui est écrit sur tout le
fronton de nos maisons communes de nos
mairies liberté égalité fraternité
bien sûr qu'il ya la sécurité évidemment
qu'il y a de la sécurité mais la
sécurité ne doit pas masquer la liberté
l'égalité et la fraternité
non merci beaucoup et guillaume ont
tardé à répondre merci voilà pour cette
nouvelle interview faite par alexandre
pouces arrête tout de suite et bien on
va rejoindre jean messier notre streamer
politique celle du genre jean batut
vient de passer pas mal de temps là avec
les internautes pour commenter cette
séance de questions d'actu qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est-ce qui les a marqués qu'est-ce
qui les a interpellés cet après midi
écoute tams et jérôme durain figure toi
le sénateur socialiste qui était mon
invité d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
qui a le plus marqué de points avec sa
question très en colère au mit au
gouvernement sur la gestion de la
manifestation est plutôt de l'évacuation
du camp de migrants de la place de la
république il y a deux jours jérôme
durain a marqué des points et c'est
surtout le gouvernement qui n'a pas
réussi à marquer la réponse de marianne
schiappa qui s'est contenté de rappeler
qu'une inspection avait été demandé à
l'igpn par le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin vie gpn
en tout cas le gouvernement est en train
de payer de payer le prix delà de la
perte de crédibilité de l'igpn depuis
plusieurs années jean castex qui a
répondu pas su plus tard à une question
similaire du groupe écologiste
là aussi en mettant en avant le travail
de l'igpn lui aussi il a eu beau
s'énerver à son tour ça n'a pas vraiment
convaincu convaincu les internautes
l'autre sujet qui a beaucoup séduit les
internautes aujourd'hui c'est les jeunes
tu l'auras un marque etam on a beaucoup
parlé des jeunes aujourd'hui au sénat on
a eu la question de emmanuel capus qui a
parlé de la fermeture des facs
on a eu la question de voler viénot qui
a parlé de la précarité des jeunes on a
lu aux questions de stéphane pieds noirs
qui a parlé de la fragilité
psychologique des étudiants
et puis et puis et puis rémy car domrémy
cardon 26 ans déjà sénateur de la
république qui a posé sa première
question au gouvernement un sénateur de
26 ans ça fait du bien de se sentir
représentés en tout cas et c'est ce que
beaucoup d'internautes ont dit
merci merci beaucoup gens pourraient
bien tout ce décryptage et tout de suite
on va prendre bien la direction de la
salle monory poursuivre et bien
l'audition justement de gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur qui est
également avec la ministre marlène
schiappa il s'exprime cet après-midi
devant les sénateurs de la commission
des lois dans le cadre du budget 2011
interne la commission des lois messieurs
les sénateurs le budget que je porte
avec la ministre déléguée